understand
[Music]
forever
thank you
[Music]
the Stars tonight What a Wonderful World
for another
life waiting for you
tonight
[Music]
waiting for you
beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
you just
[Music]
got
survive in the world
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
the power now
yeah
I want Power oh there you go
wait wait wait
uh uh okay we're in business this is
good uh hello everybody Welcome to our
competitive Jenga tournament it's Junior
sports everybody Sports
um uh I am Emma Fife I am a senior video
producer at fandom part of the greater
fandom Giant Bomb Game Spot Brands uh
joining me on my team today is Bailey
Myers
hi everyone and then over on the other
couch we have got Jeff Grubb howdy
everybody and Dan Reichert your Esports
athletes chicken Sports yeah definitely
Sports athletes bro Esports fit my life
practicing Jenga to be disrespected this
way please oh good great it's going to
be really embarrassing when you lose
today then I can't foresee that
happening uh also joining us today we
have Jan Ochoa uh
I like that you're just doing a dance to
introduce yourself there Jan
dab
yeah
and Dave Klein
team team Dance all right uh also
joining us on the station today we have
two very special guests we have Chris J
Alice
and Ethan Trainor damn nerds okay Ethan
is uh there's a lot of energy happening
I would say for the morning but it is
actually afternoon
technically afternoon uh yes so the way
that this is uh going to work is we're
gonna play a game of Jenga the rules are
you are allowed to do a little tappy tap
uh to like gauge how loose a block is
How likely you are to topple the entire
Tower but uh once you start to move a
block you are committed to that block
and you're playing European rules okay
yeah European rules yeah sure I've been
in that scene okay yeah great yeah
they aren't perfectly aligned I don't
think I've scene but usually it's like a
perfect yeah this is not um that's not
how this works uh spoiler alert this is
not Jenga this is the junga okay and we
bought it in an alley extreme Jenga this
is giant toppling blocks uh apparently
Jenga could not uh or or maybe they do
have the patent on perhaps a certain
shape of tumbling blocks uh so this is
what we're working with today people uh
all right I nominate uh one of team
Ethan and Chris what what is your team
name today explode explosioner Lord okay
team explosion murder Lord oh it's gonna
be ours yeah that was gonna be yours
should have talked about this yeah you
really it's embarrassing yeah yikes
yikes uh okay Dave and Jan
Dave and Jan Dave and Jan all right and
grubbin Reichert
the cool dudes the cool dude yeah
cool handsome dudes thgs yeah uh and
Bailey and I of course are uh Team toxic
plastic girl
we came prepared team shirts can I buy
one of those shirts could have brought
shirts yeah I'm gonna buy one of those
you want one of these I'll get you one
yeah you can get a toxic plastic Girl
Shoot shirt so these teams are up first
should they just get going yeah let's
get going all right all right do they
have like a quarter or something decide
who goes first yeah yeah rock paper rock
paper scissors yeah good ideas got it
all right who's no pressure okay we're
doing best of three years that's just
one Rock Paper Scissors Shoot to the
death oh I like Christmas already
oh they're both going scissors
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh yeah use your choice yeah whatever
whoever you want to go first goes first
it's your call yeah you choose all right
all right team Jan and Dave all right
the scissoring strategy did not work out
well for Jim so he's gonna go in there
and see if he can make it up on the
Jenga board
oh
oh he's showing it a little bit of love
Janet is a very calm man we work with
him and I think that's going to work to
his Advantage
he's immediately going for the bottom
piece that's a heel move to start that's
a heal move Jan we haven't decided what
we're gonna do if we just immediately
knock it down
that was Hasty well done Jan
oh boy all right that's you guys
all right so you guys your turn closure
he's the resident Jenga Champion so I'm
gonna hey
he's uh assessing it
see he's doing a technique called
speaking to the blocks yeah oh you see
that's a loose one that's a loose one
step in a Lucy juicy Goosey yep oh fear
not got some Sway and in some Villages
he's known as the man check out his
polish game here
to blocks
there it is
now he's got to place it on top let's
see how he goes
he changes up at the last second there
was some swaying okay but he drops it
and we're good oh all right back over to
Dave and Jan from Team Dave and Jan
have you guys considered dejan
[Music]
I want to see commitment to that
touching is there an apostrophe there
all right two okay
okay all right there we go Dave oh there
we go
whoa whoa It's Going Down
oh there we go there we go that's my guy
here we are
building relationships building Jenga
Towers
don't feel good about that I feel like I
went for the easy one
I feel really bad I don't want to lose
right in the first move I have to go
yeah oh yeah you gotta trade off all
right this is this is not a oh a team
one team member
is it Archer no no
how do you forget about yourselves it's
a turtle alternating no no it's a
tournament we're not playing yet we're
not playing yet we're playing them yeah
yeah I like sitting down I'm not getting
up yeah
so some backstage shatter he's actually
never played Jenga before
ever really really for shoot yeah so
yeah
you can touch it a little tap to see too
much loose why am I giving you advice
you're the one that you're moving
yeah come come coach him all right so
what we want to do here is
one to push the bottom pull out
you you want you want that pulled out to
be so satisfying that when you pull it
out it'll go
okay all right no pressure here I think
our best bet is yeah Dave how you guys
feeling about this so far
I'm really nervous and scared he's he's
holding he's the rock for us he's the
rock of the team the rock we call him
Dwayne there's a lot of movement there
okay a lot of movements it's not moved a
lot so far so if you want to abandon
ship don't move the table
now you you could keep testing other
pieces if you want
I don't think it's cheap enough it is
okay yeah uh so I'm gonna do it I'm
actually looking
okay
I mean that's the name of Jing sports
that's just what it's like
this is the first time I've ever done
Django with commentary normally it's
just like hmm
the man was too stunned to speak
you could go for the anything below the
third row I think
lots of movement that don't look too
good I think abandoned ship
okay
he believes in himself
and that's the most important aspect of
that in physics
yeah you could however you got to get
that hard tap spare no expense on the
tables so
yeah we have scoured the Streets of San
Diego and said give me something that
needs a matchbook under one leg Yeah our
Artisan tables yes yeah can we
get somebody to
to check and see if this table is stable
I can tell you that I don't think it is
this is perfectly regulation
we had the referee out before the game
started to make sure
I defer to uh Grubbs professional Jenga
expertise
you're pulling up you're pulling up
you're pulling up my father before my
fall out pull towards you from a long
line of Jenga Champions yes
are we supposed to yell Django when it
falls is that part of the rules okay
all right yeah yeah this is an actual
Jenga though
no pressure yeah
[Music]
you're shaking the tower too much
oh my goodness gracious God
watch it okay
what
I think that's illegal
I think that's illegal yeah
here we go
[Music]
it's not gonna go well
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
Jan
akaroo
Chad's already went oh my God best
teammate ever he's like it's like this
you know dang that is murderous
tricks all the time oh constantly you
can't even let him celebrate no no
like
the stoic nature of Jan Ochoa it's
frightening
[Music]
honestly I'm I'm looking for a horny
harder explosion bunnies whatever their
name was because I said murder Lord
that's what I said
that feels a bit tighter
at the bottom I would have gone bottom
middle personally oh wow oh yeah that's
that's the brave move
another piece is coming with them but he
got it he hasn't
it
nicely done and Dave like a glue okay ah
yes Steve has a vision oh
all the stars all the stars are here
all right that's back to you guys
this shot clock strategy they got is
actually very intimidating I'm
frightened of you too we just go like
ninjas we just go silent stealthy fast
your turn while they're celebrating uh
you know sneak in there get it done yeah
operate like life don't let anyone
celebrate just get in
I gotta take a zoom call real quick I'm
gonna just I'm gonna let him do it for
me because um
you're my spirit animal I need you I
gotta believe in yourself what do I do
if
just try it you got it famous last words
all right I need I need your help
all right
I recommend taking the bottom middle
block
hold that one
stomping stomping around is good yeah
that it helps yeah it's solidifies it
solidified as much as you possibly can
yeah
thank you
okay turned up there actually he's going
for attack oh okay I think yep that's uh
I think we've found a make sure possible
winner
okay come on
what the hell is that oh my God what
hold on no way hold on hold on hold on
live streams
wait hey wait are we doing like PG PG-13
commentary there you see you see this
[__] what is this oh my God for the
folks at home in all my almost 30 years
of living I have never seen a Jenga game
have this
look at this sport we're athletes we
respect the business
I think we're redefining how the sport
of Competency
I believe three pack San Diego 2023. you
gave me a heart attack Brian is a
respectful athlete
he protects the business because we
totally planned that right
[Music]
Jan's cool that's how Jan did Dan is so
cool look at him Ninja
I think Jan's cool as hell yeah oh yeah
you couldn't even complain I'm feeling
really good about her eyes if Jim goes
every single time would have been so
powerful you would have lost probably
but it would have been powerful
okay
[Laughter]
all right well you know what they say uh
some of the best things are made under
pressure
who says that
oh everybody all right carry on
it all right
how much longer do you think you can
keep this up though uh barely
barely we're hanging on by a thread
on a facade I like The Stance back here
that's a good stance yes yeah
he found a loose one baby
showboating is disrespectful
and he lays it on top
all right not entertained
Dave it's okay you do this buddy Ethan
has a peanut gallery over here yeah not
to jump
go go at the top one two three four row
four middle
no no one up
there we go
no I think James played Jenga before
touch it
Dave take the one that's sticking out
you won't do it
yeah don't do it you wait do it you
won't do it
committed to that one now did you have
to do that one now
dude
down
I'm yelling timber
yeah that's easy easy oh my God you got
it I I am one David is clearing away
from me oh Dave it's almost clear
oh part one the smart one
Dave plays like I like my eggs over easy
that was easy that was easy I wasn't
nervous at all okay so just remember
Chris you're up
stealth pudding
the floor is so sensitive over there
right now
[Music]
Good Vibes don't Spirit Bomb this stop
it stop it no Spirit bombs
damn drum solo
yeah that kick drum might send it yeah
you're right actually wait hold on hold
on
yeah you're the people's Jenga person
excuse me this is junga
[Music]
it's his own partner that drum rolls
people know what they're talking about
with them strategically I have to raise
some questions about this
[Music]
Dave and I oh no
use the force
oh
but you stopped you stomped
it's still kind of old black son
no you're parallel three yeah yeah stick
it in love the love the drive though
uh
I noticed Dave and I each round are
getting progressively lower to the floor
okay now
slowly back over here all right the
shrinking jave team gonna make their
move grub stomped very hard in
excitement
I've ever really seen in my life since I
I can't I my heart is in my throat and
I'm not even actively playing right now
ladies and gentlemen there's a lot of
sweat up here but there is Janice
Dan I keep talking about how cool you
are don't blow it nightmare of chinga
he's found something it's moving he
makes ice cold ice cold and slowly backs
away
it is a frightening thing to witness up
close
holy crap I think by the end of this
we're going to turn into Snakes by how
low we get
quads have to be sore
he's gonna do a running jump he's going
to outside count oh he's getting
external help not outside counsel what
the hell
under Europe
he's doing the side shimmy shuffle dance
to move up close to it trying not to
frighten the Jenga set
think Woody thoughts
[Music]
oh that is good
no pressure
does that look like he has a lot of
options here
use the force
a lot of movement up top as he goes for
this one he's still just testing though
no commitment
you can't do the top three rows so that
there's that row of three right there
you can go that fourth row
that's your friend that's the first one
you can do first legal row
he's not feeling great about that either
with a block today I feel like they're
pretty good complaining about the
tightness this is a big issue for him
my goodness
that's okay
you don't got it maybe more friction
than any Jingo set should have I believe
in you man
all right he sees something happening
there but he's not he's still not happy
with it
oh
he's gonna move around he's gonna put it
there was movement there was it's very
close to a commitment but uh oh now
announcement it's committed but I think
he feels good about this one too
this does seem to be the piece that was
right
just a little bit of movement up top he
is almost all the way out last inch
there and there we go that's my squad
now he's got a place exactly but so far
so good
and he drops it gingerly on top
Dave I'm sorry there's a wiggle now
there because it's getting
pretty precarious I don't envy Dave here
no
I normally do
immediately it just wastes no time on
team jave very impressive just Killers
absolute murderers they should be
investigated
it's all on you Chris
hey Chris no matter what this boy
excellent game this has been an
excellent match hey you're a natural at
this you're talking like a sober well I
don't believe in you anymore you want to
prove me wrong you're talking like I'm a
just Jenga
we're still in it it's simple save it
for the finals just remember just
remember that that middle that middle
one just remember that middle round
don't touch that middle row because that
is what that block is sitting on
anything the one that is barely sticking
out
essentially
you do that Rogue your only opponent now
now so oh wait wait yes yes yes that is
the fourth no wait shoot he just took
that middle one oh wait no no no no no
okay hey you're good did you test how
tight that one is right there that
fourth row that middle one
if you want to go over here and help him
okay
you should take the one that's sticking
out gently gently pull that one pull
that one test it I'm just gonna keep
suggesting that until someone's Brave
and powerful enough to do it
how are we doing how are we doing he's
breathing is it tight do you feel it got
a little wiggle room he's waxing oh I
think he's waxing off now
Jeff would the kids call this poggers
yes this is I do believe this is not
poggers okay or we're poggers adjacent
at the very least I see
wow very Expo he's committed to the
speech now though
karate
here I believe waxing off on stage is
really calming his nerves
he succeeds
the move's not finished moves not
finished
stop squatting for a second
gently
Jan is in Cobra pose all you just
walking dogs
going to that place he hears voices in
his head
honestly just had back surgery
just like I showed you with them puppets
uh no you no you can't do it that is
legal so far yeah we have wait I thought
it was under the third one
because I got elephants
[Music]
another upward facing dog here
everyone's very uptight I am one pit
bull scream away
Timber
come on everybody sing it with me it's
just moving his shoulders
look up by him
and his turn's over wow
he's using the polar bear method
remember the blocks are more afraid of
you than you are of them
what an athlete Jana choice
rarely have I ever seen anything so
beautiful in my entire life
gotcha kid
how did you catch a shot clock at a
certain point how are we doing it yeah
all right okay I need both yeah when did
you notice that bottom piece was one
that you were gonna go for I didn't I
felt it I felt the bottom he felt the
bottom
it's uh one of his main moves my
goodness he's moving the table next
no it does we said it does okay that's
how we played so far because there's one
two three and that's four
yeah I thought it was three full ones
okay we have done one where let's okay
let's pull from that before so whoa look
at that
he is got it and it's good there it is
Boom Soccer Locker he's flexing at it
that has got to be helping
and he's gonna drop it
that's no Jinga oh god oh that's how you
guys that is so slapping the floor it
was about to tear a quad from underneath
like a bank job Shane Old Mac right in
front of us
frankly I'd love to see it seriously
like where's the ESPN broadcast at this
point
I didn't even think this was gonna last
this long lots of testing
he's touched just about every piece on
this board so far
he is not sure what he's gonna have to
make a bold move
there it is looks pretty good that looks
good there's a there is some movement
but it's coming out it's sliding out and
he's good
[Music]
and that's no Jinga and then there he
goes
back into his hole
what is happening right now
how are you guys feeling over there
I'm feeling like this realistically I
expected this game to be over like 15
minutes ago I think we all did
yeah we thought we were playing a
tournament uh now I think we're just
watching the match of this Tower we had
a bracket power is a perfect
representation of my mental health right
now somehow it is stable and I don't
know how other people are touching it
all the time
they keep pulling at it and I'm like no
you'll you'll keep tearing it up and
somehow I'm still standing
slowly approaching
but you could see he's got the eye of
the tiger
okay
uh can you Flex the dust off like in a
kung fu movie all right yeah of course
yes he's worried about get it over
hey
I'm just going to take a guess here
hey hey wait just to assess the
situation that's the stability of this
very bottom row one this one the fourth
row for the bottom is One Piece
six row is One Piece
I don't even know anymore
Another one not that one now that one
not that one test the stability of these
two
no no no these two right here test that
test the stability of that oh Jan
getting up in there too tight
lots of squatting
stop stop it very silly completely legal
under these rules okay wait okay wait
hey uh I think this will be a good time
to ask our panel here
if we do not complete a move
in their movements were to cause the
tower to fall since we would not have
completed a move yet would they be the
ones who lose
yes yes
all right if you're moving oh yeah
whoever causes it to fall loses yeah
yeah
all right hey uh how how is the middle
one on that four or that fifth row I
think you gotta you gotta go bold
on that fifth fifth row right there I
think you got to pull the tablecloth
how was that one how was it test it test
it test yeah yes that is a fair game yes
not a lot of movement oh he's found one
I think he likes now uh oh oh
careful careful
careful
uh he is now committed yeah he has
committed oh wait and it's moving it is
coming out inch by inch and a full inch
is clear he's got the full on time yep
slowly giving some gentle loving
we've seen crazier Maneuvers happen in
this game so
he wants you to cheer give him your
attitude yeah
they're boo lots of Swain they're a bull
horn in the audience yeah where'd that
come from from the bullhorn oh okay
there's a bullhorn guy yeah bullhorn
okay man
oh my God he doesn't know about the
bullhorn guy that's so embarrassing
careful careful we have we have swaying
careful
that is most of the way also just
remember this is his first time
a true Jenga prodigy
was born today there's nothing on his
face is intense right now oh there we go
[Music]
do you have anything to say
oh
[Laughter]
well done
what a game well played yes yeah hey
let's give it let's give a hint for our
opponents here
this is all for charity
all right
congratulations to all of our players
today again we thought it was going to
be a tournament turned out to just be
the match of a lifetime uh thank you so
much to Chris and Ethan for joining us
uh we're gonna be taking a quick break
but we will be back very soon uh with
some intensely competitive Mario party
so don't you worry more friendships will
be destroyed today it's gonna be rough
did you say Mario Party
okay what are the odds I get in on that
oh yeah we know we are we actually for
fit
uh
[Music]
uh thanks everybody
getting on the Mario Party
[Music]
to remember
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
very later
[Music]
thank you
yourself
[Music]
all right
replacing replacing cycle with your
answers
[Music]
I can see your story
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so deeply
I can see
my story
I can believe
in one
meant to be
I can see
foreign
[Music]
coming faster into the water
with us
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
never imagine
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
every
[Applause]
where
[Music]
each other
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight What a Wonderful World
for another
life waiting for you
in the
tonight
what a wonderful
for
[Music]
waiting for you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
remember to take care
[Music]
how can you
everything
[Music]
turn down
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
cling to the night
[Music]
and not your own
a life that you never thought you know
when you watch me
[Music]
awaken for love but not your own a life
that you never thought you'd know
[Music]
how could we let this happen
in the right way
[Music]
thank you
for you
[Music]
for me
foreign
[Music]
for you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
everything
[Music]
else
her home I guess yeah
they did All Connect as soon as I came
out here yeah I think that hey I got one
mine's trying to connect and when I move
it it bounces hit L and R okay hit that
one oh wait wait now I'm out oh no
that's sorry that's my problem I I'm I'm
ruining it too many people controlling
too many cooks in the kitchen and we're
not even overlooked yet
okay all right now I'll hit your little
yeah
it's gonna be the hardest part I know
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
and if you're just like hearing voices
from the stage area don't be shy about
wandering this way and coming to join us
as we ruin some friendships playing
Mario party today my name is Emma Fife I
am a senior video producer at fandom uh
and I've got a bunch of great Pals and
competitors here on the stage with me
who I'm sure I will never speak to again
uh after this hour or so uh Jeff would
you like to introduce yourself next yeah
I'm Jeff grub of giant bomb and I'm
going to dominate I'm going to destroy
and I will and I will leave nothing but
crumbly little bits of human body parts
up here when I'm done so look out for
that Bailey uh I'm Bailey Myers I'm a
producer and writer at fandom and they
don't know what they're in for going up
against me on this I'm about to destroy
yeah
I'm Dan Reichard and first and foremost
Mario Party athlete I'm in it for the
sport I'm not here to be anyone's enemy
or anything I'm just it's going to be a
fair respectful Honest Game and um May
the best player win I've actually Jeff
can attest to this I've never lost Mario
Party on the internet you know I've lost
I've literally I literally beat him the
last time we played I have never
literally beaten it and I hope you all
have a great game uh he's just the
biggest liar the biggest liar maybe I've
ever met sorry you've never lost on the
internet no on a stream okay well we are
on the internet right that's what I'm
saying that's what I'm saying I mean my
element right now okay I'll get ready to
break your streak I guess okay we'll see
we'll see uh so this is Mario Party 2
that we are going to be playing today
this is per uh Bailey's request all
right yeah bill you want to get a setup
best one Mario Party two is the best
because the Rangers dressed in the
costumes to match the boards that they
play on the cowboy map is very good in
two okay why Luigi's not here yet yeah
still a great game yeah maybe the best
Mario Party
um the fact that Waluigi isn't there so
that's really saying something yay I
don't want to accidentally hit back on
this is it uh is it B it's a it's
definitely a trying that oh there we go
okay
[Music]
we don't want people fainting yeah yeah
mystery link mystery land what what
no way oh can we do the wrong wrong
course does it just decide for you just
decided for us all right all right
we can go back if you want if you want
if you want we can go back Now's the
Time to pull the plug it's your guess's
call you guys are the experts yeah you
really want to go back you have cowboy
hats in the UK there's a Hooten nanny I
want to do the hootenanny yeah yeah okay
let's go back all right all right all
right let's see here all right
this or uh the back button I think
player one maybe hits the the minus
button yeah hey there we go and the
reset game reset
Mind Games already is someone playing
mind games huh good say
I was up on stage I chose the right
course I don't know what happened yeah I
don't know sure
so what is the best Stage the
Cowboys yeah yeah this may sound like a
dumb question what's a Hooten Nanny oh
you'll know it when you see it all right
all right here we go suffice to say it's
worth every penny definitely get one
western land okay here we go uh siren
land western land and this is the cover
star the the Cowboys yeah totally yeah
but I do know that I had that poster on
my wall please all right let's speed on
through this okay I'm not touching it
how many of you try to touch anything
make sure it's the a button a button a
button a button
[Music]
nailed it
okay no Oreo nice
bonus bonus bonus bonus bonus play
always
let's go
[Music]
now Bailey and Reichert are both uh Avid
Mario Party 2 players uh I cannot
remember the last time I played Mario
Party 2s
I'm mostly here hoping for like three
beginner's luck it's not like yeah no I
think you have the I'm my money's on you
okay I I have a Mario Guinness World
Record so if I was a better man I'm
sorry I'm sorry okay Guinness World
Record it counted yes I could have
played Mario Party
game with Mario
so it was more like a quantity but not
quality situation
excuse me there's some very important a
lot happening right yeah sure uh
Bowser's in town we gotta kill him
after a good start thank you everybody
[Music]
all right all right this is no Garfield
lasagna party though I'll say that for
sure that was garbage
[Music]
good luck becoming the Superstar I'm
Wario I'm Yoshi
yeah banjo with the star on it is this
one of the ones where we can uh just
like taunt people mercilessly the entire
time okay
yeah a lot of times
wait is totaling a little banjo all
right here we go Luigi
yeah big money here we go
I just tested to see if the taunting was
working and to hear it I held the
controller up to my ears I don't know
why I did that because you're a thousand
years old the timing is working because
I can hear Peach going yeah yeah corner
all right no whammies nice
[Music]
no one's impressed
by the crowd yells left
I would go right that'd definitely go
right bud
[Music]
all right nice nice
let's go great start oh happy perfect
good one
everyone loves this game this is where
yeah it's where we count it's great
music it's a game of skill oh yeah you
don't want the uh the beehives and then
take as many fruits as the number shown
you just go wrong button oh yeah okay
all right let's do it okay
stop stop okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right the rich get richer
damn it
wait this map okay this is a very tough
time for three also
uh I'm about to get out aren't I yep yes
you are I super am that's okay
yeah that's the honeycomb you know not a
great start for me but on the bright
side I did walk away
it's getting stung by a bunch of bees
now not a good start I had to get the
one loss out of the way so that right
wins there's nowhere to go run up and
again didn't walk away empty-handed I'm
walking out of this thing in second
place baby you get a coin yeah I did
[Music]
Maybe
go to
for me
okay no okay okay
that's a good one yeah yeah
damn team right now that's a terrible I
love this that's a fun game all right
we're the two veterans and we both lost
on purpose
I will chip away at like Michelangelo
wow
God the skill that's on display here
it's really remarkable yes
and this is the esportiest of them all
[Music]
oh
no
can I pick zero
Rob is that you all right come on give
it to me you know you love me babies
did he just break dance are we all heels
I get food every time okay yeah
I love that for us
San Diego Stakes
your football team's a joke oh my God
I'd rather be in Los Angeles
I drew it all I don't like Los Angeles
okay whatever
where's the uh
all right
I just blindly chose a direction yeah I
think I honestly I think if I try to
like be clever it's not gonna work out
for me yeah
there's a shop okay
I'm feeling like a crazy delay I don't
know if you guys are having that oh are
we preemptively blaming your control no
no no no I wouldn't do that where's the
switch it's a poor Workman Dan uh
[Music]
oh it's over there on the right side
you're probably you probably want a
little bit more line of sight okay
[Music]
I like that I have a built-in excuse
It's good yeah and it's real it's real
sure
sure I'll still win
oh
the right items
[Music]
it's like the soundtrack of my life
every time I go shopping
I got very confused
all right what's it gonna be
wow
oh [__] okay
that's the three rules
[Music]
feeling great feeling good feeling
positive
oh I gotta make a choice I'll go this
way
[Music]
buy an item ooh
I will buy
a skeleton key yeah definitely spend 10
coins on that yeah
that gets you a bonus star and I'm not
skeletons I think it unlocks skeletons
yeah that's I mean I'm a big fan of that
you know I'm just gonna do it all right
in the future
wait no we're heading towards okay okay
hey
[Music]
oh man I'm not I don't have the patience
for this one
[Music]
look how cute we are little cars doesn't
matter what direction you press
tilt yeah all right all right okay let's
go
so cute it's shaped like our controller
no freakish heads Luigi's decapitated
head
[Music]
all right
oh
she let's go
[Music]
how many laps are there
you know it's a normal amount
[Applause]
[Music]
got a cart
big money
or six
I should say yes right yeah no no that's
the Batman actually you should just view
the map
the bad star yeah
[Music]
Luigi
telling you my decision to get a
skeleton key is really going to pay off
at some
points
San diegans
[Music]
okay
I want a town on that ukulele oh
you play the ukulele
right because they probably don't have
ukuleles
is there enough slack on that that we
could pull it a little closer
Oh Hang on we're gonna find out
it's me
okay
wow
oh God it's chance time okay Our Fate is
in Emma's hand all right we've got us
happening early reverse
here we go
do not
or Peach
[Applause]
and then Peach
what the hell
[Laughter]
this is how it goes
it's not what I wanted this is how it
goes excellent thank you thank you
we're gonna be stuck staring at this
nonsense foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my gosh I can't see I cannot see at
all
wow
I don't think I've ever lost that one
before something's something in the air
tonight all right Luigi yeah I just
remember when I was in first place like
30 seconds ago sorry
I was trying to get it for myself
um but it didn't work out you know you
can get you can get him back because
he's got so many coins you could okay
you didn't want to steal his coins
that's an interesting choice to make but
sure
I guess I should have stole coins huh
yeah
the right choice
I just I was so hung up on the star I
didn't think about it
[Music]
all right
I am wasting a golden mushroom is what
I'm doing that's good
all right pretty good all right I'll
take it I'll take it I'll take it I'll
take it that's
dirty 20 baby
yes uh-huh yeah there you go that's fine
give me five coins I'll get over it very
soon
you could get him back for not stealing
my coin for stealing his coin you know I
could do that
you're in first place I'm operating with
the computer operations
you know any Petty grudges or whatever
look at over 20. we're good we're good
oh I got all my money back that's nice I
love that for me
yeah I used to do that oh I'm just gonna
look
milk well here's the thing
[Music]
for a second I miscounted I thought I
would be landing on the happening space
I'm like I'm gonna get hit by a train if
I don't ride the train and isn't that
just a metaphor for life but no it turns
out it's not a metaphor at all I was
fine it just didn't count good the train
would push you past the Stars absolutely
[Music]
yes oh no you are in cahoots with the
switch
I have a connection you just bump into
each other there you go yeah yeah yeah
go die die in lava
[Music]
all right we'll get Wario
this is gonna be a nobody win situation
I think so no ever go for Wario
[Music]
this feeling really good
balls wait does this game suck
I'm having a good time no no I thought I
loved bumper I would have been good with
hexagons
come on yes yes I'm not I have not been
putting my money where my mouth is so
far with how I've been playing this game
and I need to turn this off
like
yeah yeah
uh no I don't think so but it takes you
past the star
[Music]
oh my God oh my God we're about to get
hit by the train because
[Music]
you are working with Dan and not in the
literal giant bum sense in the working
with him right now here on stage thank
you I would never work with him thank
you group I thought we said Noah I got
knocked out wait he gave me money he
gave me money
oh my god
when you're a good person oh my god when
you're a good person oh yeah that's the
secret you're manifold yeah okay all
right oh no
[Music]
uh oh
I have no coins no stars crazy gutter
yes as long as it's not day at the races
I don't care
you just pick and watch foreign
[Music]
stupid fish
why is it shaped like this oh
no stay in the line Yoshi that was not
good
what do you mean what the hell I'm
better
inside the lines the whole bottom look
at that I guess I did two what you're an
art critic now too oh yeah
[Music]
throw me a pity
that was great I've had so much caffeine
my hands are good you know yeah totally
I changed my mind Mario party tonight
all right we are looking at the map one
two three four one two one two we'll
just go on up I guess
[Music]
let's go have enough money for the star
but I got knocked away from where the
star is so I can't even get happy I like
that you said I got knocked away like
you had nothing to do with it I had
nothing to do with it that was just God
punishing me for being close to Dan oh I
see that's just indicating that I asked
for a game
I was like why do I I thought I thought
I skeleton it's cool because
um the gate the key will be like really
like what I got on there
look it in its face and spit on it
[Music]
all right
he's heading straight at them
what the hell I didn't do anything
that's a problem bro I didn't like I hit
the buttons to go in he literally got
removed I don't understand
oh what am I doing
no no
[Music]
this is fun they're cheering do you hear
them cheer you hear them cheer
[Music]
but the thing is me being terrible at
mini games is like across the board
unless it's an in-game card game like
I'm great at gwent but not a lot else
[Music]
one two three four five six or one two
three
four five six four one two three four
five six and I have to go past this
stupid Bank
um all right I'm taking no wrong moves
anything you can do here all around
moves
no
what's a dueling glove do you just slap
someone in the face you can like
challenge them like literally yeah okay
not Stars just coin okay yeah
[Music]
yeah I'm just gonna land on a red space
you all can fight me unless yo she lands
on her in space and then you all can
fight us oh get a hoot and you can't
afford it
I'm poor so sad
oh
all right
oh I like this one all right that's a
shock dropper yeah this is I love how
the one versus three games it's either
all of you are trying to kill me or I'm
trying to kill all of you this is the
ladder so we just stay on the thing and
jump okay yeah yeah
relax try not to die
[Music]
oh my gosh I apparently did not
understand
very much in The Wanderers favor kind of
one the important thing is really fun
thing before it was that hard it was so
much fun yeah remember you're being
sarcastic no this is the Legendary game
series new very popular Mario Party
oh
wasn't there like didn't they send a
letter to Game Informer thanking them
for the review because Game Informer
always gave it like three out of ten and
Nintendo sent us a plaque that said
Nintendo Thanksgiving for another
well-written and insightful uh reviews
of Mario Party and it was a three out of
time yeah the most sarcastic thing
Nintendo's ever again a lot of time
that's so silly I should steal something
I think a um I think a three is being
generous
thank you
Luigi button match by Mash I kind of
don't think hitting a does anything
frankly I don't think it does yeah
it gives you a sense of purpose
give me your money
oh my gosh I got 62 now yeah I can steal
a star and then almost another buy one
now you have 59. cool
okay
nope yeah nope I don't have anything I'm
good for it I'm good I haven't had any
money the whole game actually just not
one of the bad ones just not one of the
best foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
appropriate
oh
my God look at the replay clearance day
look at this
way we're seeing this right I don't know
what it's their first time seeing this
this is what it's always like
it's literally always trying to warn
everyone
it gave me one coin well I just full
lost money I got some coins I profited
it it was great great I'm really happy
for you 78 wow
all right
it's doing so good there for a minute
I'm still doing great great I'm really
happy for you again
all right we're on a team everything
else okay everything else
I have to really okay just hit a to play
your instrument it's rock band okay all
right okay
it's got a bob on his as
[Music]
I forgot I was yesterday yeah the delay
is not good no what's up with this one
[Music]
hey mess up hey no doing all right
I'm gonna try something
again just a throw ride
the ultimate thrower yeah
we did we'll get him next time and now
yeah going down
[Music]
I need to call my therapist just hang on
the Train's got facial hair yeah it
looks great
dozens of polygons
yeah like at least 12. yeah
[Music]
you know you do have enough money for a
hoop Nanny oh boy I don't remember if I
actually getting anything oh wait okay
be careful with this be careful with
this do it I'm gonna be really careful
don't do anything for ash here no I
would never
oh there's the delay
all right
Luigi I did so good
I was really really trying there
I was like come on Bailey turn the game
around that wouldn't have been sporting
thank you for doing it no yeah no you're
right I did that I did it on purpose
I I think Chance time is silly and bad
and I don't like it it's having zero
stars and one coin good yeah yeah yeah
it's like golf yeah lowest score wins I
have two moves left
uh I'll go that way if you go to the
left you can use your skeleton I know
that's what I'm doing
I don't know
[Music]
all right okay okay yes
just hit the button that's over your
head yes okay all right it's a or b okay
when it's over your head you hit that
button
[Music]
there we go
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
hey Dan how you doing yes yeah
I felt bad for my co-worker yeah yeah we
are so good at lumberjacking
we had it we're only going for a while
The Lumberjack off of all time I got you
two digits in my coin total now I'm
about to use my skeleton key and then
it's over
oh cool he gave me money give me uh yeah
foreign
[Music]
I've never lost
oh I was gonna go that way and then I
decided to go the other way and wound up
losing 20 coins and all my non-existent
stars pretty unfortunate when you think
about it but this new lesson to me to
just never drive
[Music]
you don't want the warplot I don't want
that why but it's so fun you don't know
where you're gonna go it's like going
into the airport and saying give me a
ticket I don't like Randomness break the
building in my Mario Party
mushroom skeleton with a face and a bow
all right
she's going the distance
cool
[Music]
I appreciate that you're welcome yeah I
really did it um
all that those fresh coins in the bank
they go in a big pile Five Points in
this Reserve okay I like that points one
day Sunday all right okay let's go let's
go
this delay oh that would be really bad
yeah
yeah they did change the name of this
one in the new game the TV in game mode
they did yeah yeah it's a straight shot
a lob shot B and you can strafe if you
hold I think CL
that's right
oh sorry all right practice game no one
practices no practice not in this area
not here not now
okay
[__] get out of here
I hated things
cool
good work Yoshi
all right all right I look so cute as a
little tank
pizza looks horrifying looks kind of
messed up four or five
tied up for a second
we're coming back hey Rob how are you
doing the number of times
the fact that I'm now in second again
you were just directed to myself
I barely have enough to even steal yeah
Mario yep he's just one Yoshi has a lot
[Music]
yeah but Wario has kids Stars
situation that stars don't really play
in
wahoo
uh you have to go all the way around
it's back by the bank where am I
up and then it's up and then you're
upper left but then up
okay I don't know I actively chose not
to go that way so you know
I would have taken the train
I'm just sad we're not playing for 50
turns
just 50 turns of torture every time 50
turns I think would give me a chance to
turn this around it's like is this do I
even feel this pain if it's not 50
turned yeah I don't know man
I think the new one Superstars you can
only do 30 is the
maximum out you can add more in the game
right which is fine so I should go this
way if you're just having such a blast
if you want to keep playing I love it I
think if you did 30 I think it doesn't
let you do that all right you always do
50.
stop it
foreign
[Music]
that's a fun game again too
are they cheering
and I'm sorry
but it really wasn't my intent with that
I was really just trying to punch you
into the lava and stay in the game all
right last 10 turns
oh thank God
[Music]
yeah yeah you should do it
you really should do it
coward they don't want enough money for
a star
seeing you I thought you were a team
player wow someone doesn't like a hoot
nanny
I have to go all the way around keep
going straight because uh if you go down
Baby Bowser's there and he only gives
money to dance
[Music]
this is one of the good courses you guys
said one of the all-time best this is
the best course wow okay double check
again just gotta double check again oh
what the bad ones look like yeah right
this is a good run
you know Yoshi's in seconds yeah
[Music]
you take the feelings out of this robot
rules
oh yeah totally totally yeah 22 points
every single time
well now I'm
gonna be if I want to get a star
I'm personally aiming to get the pity
Stars
[Music]
oh I can't or I won't be able to afford
a star
all right Nanny I'm just gonna do it
because there's no way I'm gonna win so
I might as well make things
entertainment I like it yeah three
[Music]
three and I don't have to go Patch baby
this way
it's a little column a little column B
okay yeah
multi-purpose
all right let's do that big moves
up here we go here we go doing that this
there's a delay concerned about this I
have faith that the game will work with
me
to jump
okay
oh my God
uh
[Music]
that's how you doing uh you know I'm
having a great time definitely uh I
would I wouldn't want to be anywhere
else yeah right at all this is truly the
most fun you could possibly have yeah
I'm gonna move the switch back so they
have a worse delay yeah I think that's a
good idea I'm so afraid to Blink in this
one yeah that's fair
I think you should blink a lot I think
that's better for your eyes probably is
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah yeah that's yeah
oh boy oh great I'm glad you told
discipline make us play Hot Rod jump
actually I think that was a whole five
one game yeah
[Music]
you have an item
one two three
yeah I think I will
oh
yeah still a star
star still a star stop stop stop
what's the hesitation
tell us your thought process yeah what's
going on here I'm being strategic oh
okay first of all I think stealing a
star is dirty and it isn't the spirit of
the game
[Music]
I
have a shot at the Coinstar
this is our this is our downfall right
here I'll take this I'll take our gas
wall
[Music]
coolant before and it kind of scares me
failure that you were the chosen one I
hope you know what you're doing
[Music]
all right never mind
nice I've never seen that done in a
freaks me out yes I'm actually scared
the level of like actual strategy there
for the bonus Stars I've never seen
I don't know how I feel about that I I
have recognized luck is not on my side
this round I have to be thinking 10
moves right ahead oh man okay okay here
I need you to put fear back into your
Hardware I do have questions
they're just really working this around
now I'm a big fan of this one
let me figure out what the Z button is
on this thing okay it is the L2 trigger
yes so uh just butt stop the higher you
go the higher you'll knock it down yeah
okay we get the very uh sensitive uh
situation back into the ground where it
belongs okay here we go
Nintendo stops doing games like this
[Music]
it looks like a tie I was a split second
ahead of you the whole time and you knew
it
I understood what was going on yeah I
totally knew it was happening
I think it was pretty clear you use your
ass
[Music]
okay
do you know what is really cool about
that wow it only moved me forward it
actually moved me forward from where I
was going and it made me skip the bank
and you don't lose it
so much for doing that yeah you're
welcome going up yes we're going up
[Music]
yeah big bunny
this is not very Coinstar review Peach
the coins are just how much you have at
the end or how much it's who hits the
Coinstar it's like you put your change
in and they take eight percent unless
you go to Amazon
number right okay yeah okay you love
that show you know it perfect
thank you
I've never played San Diego again
okay all right oh uh pop balloons okay
uh tank tank controls the ass balloons
be last person standing or sitting in a
car
yeah all right
everyone go for looking for bands yeah
absolutely
oh my God what the heck
how do I freaking no [__] you
good fine good
[Music]
I'm pressing right and it went backwards
see you said Resident Evil take controls
you've never played already
backwards let's not take controls that's
broken were you holding your controller
like
you know what you should do is
yes
[Music]
what are you gonna do for me I'm gonna
help you win so we both profit here okay
so it's the exact same controls as the
last game not killing each other we're
just getting money and putting it in our
money pile okay
okay
oh nice get it back if they've given us
oh okay wait hold on I don't remember
I don't know I'm trying I don't I'm so
bad at this okay sorry you're doing
great Bailey it's okay buddy
whatsoever
foreign
[Music]
are you gonna train ride ride that train
go for it Luigi
[Music]
okay
having a good time
yeah this is really fun it's like a
party yeah it's like a party good
[Music]
yeah okay I am the fact that you look at
this View and not the other view is
genuinely disconcerting well but you get
the wider scope of the city yeah yeah
it's all right I need to really look at
it right here let's see
okay at least these streets make more
sense than San Diego
oh
[Music]
open it yeah yeah baby
yeah if you're not gonna use it that
would be stupid
you use the key yeah the star is left
but you used the key I did use the key
I'm going up yeah I'm there's no way I'm
gonna win so at this point I'm committed
to my life you are in second place yeah
that's a good point 80 coins on the line
here wait no somebody oh I I don't know
no it's everybody okay
he's got a great blast I hate this game
all right just pick a thing and hope you
don't die yeah
okay okay
all right me and Mario Bros any of the
other ones I'm so good at it I would be
good at grab bag
I'm good at facelift
uh okay I'm gonna pick
whoo
[Music]
yeah
because it's my favorite color
oh boy
game of skills
every day the darkness closes more and
more every moment
I really want to just win a luck game
but I can't because I'm the least lucky
person in the world
oh no okay
oh
how's it going it's going good everyone
crap good job next wait away the whole
time yeah
but also kind of just falls down a
little and I find that charm
[Music]
I think Luigi rubs his butt on the
ground like a dog yeah
okay let's go
this has been going a very non-baily way
this whole time would you call this a
lucky one six yeah one eight ten eleven
but before but now
[__]
there you go you're welcome
[Music]
perfect
okay
can you guys do me a huge favor
no helping other people I wasn't saying
to help me
I really wanted him to get the coin
because I think he deserves it he works
really hard
[Applause]
[Music]
damn it
yeah it doesn't look good for old Luigi
all right I might see you
[Music]
girls get fruit off trees
it's really the music that makes it feel
fun yeah
[Music]
great
yeah yeah
I was really hoping you would go for the
coin no well I got the coins
because I work really hard they're
saying
[Music]
Bailey's name was registered as what
bewley yeah no they someone was just
like having a moment when they were
entering my name in the registration
it's like Beulah or something wow I have
a lot of coins there's a lot of coins
out there a lot of coins out there I
don't know if I'm getting the coin star
or even if there's an unlucky star that
they added retroactively for the online
version that'll be me oh my God I
realize I have 17 coins
oh yeah you do
who could have done this like this I
might as well not even be playing this
week it's it's a good thing that you're
not like right by the star though that
would be so annoying for you
if you can ruin someone else's day
all right
I don't want that anymore I've decided I
don't want that oh
it's not there
no extra Bowsers
15 coins for Bowser well
at least you didn't take anything I
don't do anything
[Music]
that's all I care about here
all right how do I get out of this yeah
wait I can just roll like a couple here
remember when Bailey chose to not steal
his stuff do you know what I actually
don't need to remember that thank you so
much I was being strategic and it felt
in my grasp oh man oh if you land on
three you get this is the action space
and if you win it then or the event or
whatever the hell you win it then you
could get the star right wait what now
the stars are great oh go do that go to
that really smart yeah thank you yeah
anytime hey what are you doing thank you
I'm hoping you resigns at this point I'm
just doing what I I'm just you know do
what I battle mini okay let's do the
thing okay
yeah I'm in fourth place I'm just gonna
choose to be a good sport have a good
yes I love grab bag if I put start
putting good sport energy at the switch
maybe I'll do better
all right go up behind them Press B
repeatedly to steal stuff out of their
bag you want mushrooms you're getting
grabbed jam on B okay spam B yeah and
you can jump too to get out of the way
so okay yeah yes
okay here we go
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
she's going she had a really rough day
remember when you told me to go there
and then we had a thing and then I stole
the thing and now I have enough for a
start yeah man whatever yeah this is
good this is good 53.
I only needed like three this is way
more than I needed I
I'm going to directly walk into the
ocean yeah
laughs
I hate him so much
so much
what did you do for this game that it
loves you sorry I've been an advocate of
my series my entire life okay sorry
publicly privately within the comfort of
my home with my family publicly podcast
yeah
okay yes yeah
[Music]
still an item man it's not all about you
looking out for number one here
okay
[Music]
still your dumb needy key
uneventful
okay okay fine
what a bad game let's do it
[Music]
and Luigi you also don't want to look
the same way as us you want to look a
different way
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my God
oh God
you just shouted the word left at him
that's where he went I'm in his head
look at him his soul just left his body
oh boy well oh here we go
I still have a chance
give me please give me a Pity thing
please take pity on me and give me a
Pity thing
[Music]
what's happening
why does the game hate me I've done
nothing but play it since it came out I
have a love affair with this game yeah I
thought I did too yeah it turns out
this is the bachelor it's got one rose
to give and it's not for Bailey
I'm glad we're all understanding this
now
[Music]
I gave you honest advice because I'm a
good person thank you and good things
happen to good people yeah stay here
clearly
[Music]
where is it okay great
by there why
[Laughter]
play that guitar toad there we go get in
there nice
okay I think I'm on the right path this
game is cruel and I hate it
have a hoot Nanny uh do it
hanging on to my money you are the
person who can have a food nanny for
very little consequence you could from
the I could use that money
for everyone else
yourself I I was promised a hoot Nanny
and so far everyone has declined what is
even the point of all doing your key he
might want to order like some ubereats
to celebrate afterwards for that I am on
principle taking your needy Keys
yeah there you go there you go have a
good sport I'm a good sport
thanks for the key
[Music]
the devastating thing is this is
actively the worst I've ever played oh
and on the most public stage I've ever
played it uh
that's something that I'm gonna have to
go to sleep thinking about for the rest
of my life a lot of athletes the bright
lights you know it's not even about
joking it's about I didn't know you were
banging the switch where was where will
the train go
uh I don't know but do it do it but the
star is right there I know I need to
feel something
don't do it do it no if you get if you
go
you can steal a star
and also buy a star yeah
[Music]
oh my God
three stars right in a row right
[Laughter]
Mario Party equivalent of a turkey
it's amazing oh my God you should go for
it yeah let's see it really suck I would
hate them I would love that
I just want to make sure you don't win
I'm gonna end your streak however
all right and then otherwise it just
sinks okay you want the money
[Music]
at all
okay
[Music]
I'm not getting anything
cool guys
[Music]
four more turns you could do something
really incredible this round
[Music]
yeah
big roll there we go oh wow high roller
[Music]
you wouldn't
oh no
um
wow just three moves huh where does the
train stop do you think three moves will
get you there I don't think the train
stops there it actually stops way around
uh in the front the wrong direction of
where you want to be I'm about to take
only five points I'm about to get run
over by a train I hope you go back and
I'm gonna lose
[Music]
that would have been so cool dude
oh
that worked out great I'm glad I took
your key All Things Considered that
weren't great
at least I got that uh
yeah yeah that seems cool yeah it was
um I was about to get a second star
actually you're about to get three stars
really good game yeah
but that's all right where'd it go at
the end of the day
dad's still over there somewhere that's
so many cool yeah well at least you guys
are getting the Coinstar and he's not
which might actually suck
okay
do-over we can do this okay
all right here we go
what the hell yeah
[Music]
oh
wow he even does it on the ball don't
spit his butt on anything he spin his
butt on the ball spin his butt on the
ball funny spot on the ball
technique he's got worms
the beach
get his plans to express
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right which way he's gonna get us to
a nanny yeah I need to hoot Nanny real
bad
uh
we go that way they have a lot of money
you know what no it's your fault I have
53. they have a lot more diamonds
foreign
[Music]
can take you there I don't know
this isn't hootenanny Over Yonder so I
think if I just keep this thing if you
go up you can plan on the action space
where I can watch again once again
embarrass myself for no reason all right
[Music]
yeah you have to catch her it's gonna
like bounce in your hands like a funny
little basketball with eyes
okay stop it
oh my God
stop whoa
stop it
[Music]
oh no
he was just
Ada yep he just stood there
yeah like that
[Music]
all right Emma let's play catch
no you have to catch it she's gonna
steal your coins
[Music]
that sucks
I can't see the star anymore oh no how
terrible for you how's my whole place I
know
[Music]
Run and Jump and don't fall yeah okay
it's just moving jump a to jump
[Music]
and it's a race and also don't fall to
your death okay and there's a delay and
there's a delay you're gonna suck yeah
it's also already not not the best of
this version of game yeah that they have
what
[Music]
[Applause]
what
[Music]
[Applause]
a good use of our time
yeah
cool great that was good
all right I just I really appreciate all
the progress we made in that last round
yeah yeah
just don't ride the train
[Music]
I'm not gonna think about it
I've stolen his star okay thank you hey
who says good things can't still happen
yeah I didn't realize how much that was
gonna benefit me
you've lost this for us well let's just
wait thanks grub yeah no problem just
like we planned
[Music]
hey
nanny
[Music]
I just really wanna know to me I think
this makes the winner of the game great
you had a really good time
[Music]
in the same spot yeah I guess so that's
what that's what a hoot nanny is yeah I
[__] hate you guys we're almost gonna
jump Luigi
this game is terrible
why did they make this thing
for something it's money laundering
that's the only education
[Music]
I've done nothing but talk about how
great it is yeah there's a lot of big
talk yeah just who Nanny again
it's okay I have so much money and no
stars I'm money rich but land poor like
the Nuvo money rich but land for the
stars are land and the money is the
money yeah it's a metaphor
awesome awesome
[Music]
I have a lot of hard thinking to do
about my relationships with my
co-workers
[Music]
I'm gonna beat you and no one's watching
brave enough to get this audience what
it was yeah that's true
[Music]
whatever whatever
yeah no I had an actual path to Victory
there in my head all mapped out and Grub
took it from me because he wanted to go
on a choo-choo ride okay
let's do it fast it makes the slide or
the show uncover stuff what picture
it'll say in the middle is this the bus
stop one I don't remember
like the number of times I've heard that
in my life
[Music]
she's got it I can do it last turn I
could do a peach
okay
last turn there it is turn baby on the
table cool
[Music]
land on a Bowser space be funny
all right hold on I'm gonna end this fun
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten yeah there we go
getting that happening star I'm gonna
show you how close I came to winning I
don't see the problem
oh no
fair play
I've started ending where you finished
yes
[Music]
Mario
yay
man
[Music]
[Applause]
no I knew it
Emma I knew you could do it yeah me too
I love the last move of the last turn
you've got to be kidding me yes yes
on the internet in perfect 1080p for
some people
okay
yeah wow I hope you do really good on
the next mini game otherwise you might
end yourself
here oh I like this one I'm in a much
better mood now actually
I'm so glad everything is going to win
the game yep go to the one that towed
he'll raise the flag and you go to that
oh yeah yeah yeah and jump and you can
bust something I don't think you can
butt stuff oh you can't no okay
you might be able to I might be wrong
though no you
absolute dirty player
[Music]
oh man
ually landed and bounce off your stupid
stomach that was really good it was not
he's just all right that is perfect we
don't know we don't know anything we
don't know
anything yet
way too many
[Music]
still it's all skill
it's my first star of the game
hey and the Coinstar and The Happening
star is also Gonna Be Mine
[Music]
volume two oh wait do we all have three
stars
wait I think you do you're gonna win
yeah
is that really what happened I got the
feed cut the feed
who could it be oh man narrative who's
gonna stop him
do it
wow congratulations
Victory from the jaws of defeat
I feel like I mean it was a really good
yeah yeah
I think I played a pivotal role
honestly please oh yeah you're welcome
that's Oreo Barrio
[Music]
so fun I love Mario party
that was incredible it was thanks so
much for defeating the true evil yeah
yeah we're all winners
look everyone was bummed about how
WrestleMania ended so I thought maybe
you have a baby face
[Music]
look at that
time
wow wow I crushed you with the mini
games it was not even close
um highest number of coins yeah yeah
yeah absolutely uh all right wow yeah
you didn't land on a single happening
space guess you're not very happening
Luigi was pretty happening yeah
[Music]
uh Against All Odds in the 11th Hour in
our Mario party uh I had a great time
that was very sweet
storybook Perfection yeah Bailey how
about you did you have a good time
playing you know I was worried about my
relationship with the switch I thought
it was mad at me or something but
actually it turns out it was just
preparing for an ultimate Betrayal on my
behalf right so it loves me more than
anyone's ever loved me including my own
family I think it didn't last place how
do you feel I just realized I am the
only one here with a third party
connection
I'll show myself out all right and
that's it everybody thanks so much for
watching thank you uh come back uh in a
little while the Creator Gauntlet will
be kicking off right here on this stage
and we will have more Mario action in
the form of Mario Kart and then a Mario
trivia tournament where
Riker perhaps you will redeem yourself
with your deep dark
yes yes thanks so much everybody we'll
see you all again in a little while
bye-bye
[Music]
I can see
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
faster into
surface
[Music]
good morning
foreign
[Music]
everyone said
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
number
[Music]
[Applause]
one now
[Music]
[Applause]
I can't remember
[Music]
[Applause]
when you asked me
[Music]
[Applause]
so far
[Music]
[Applause]
tonight
What a Wonderful World
for another
life waiting for you
in the
form
waiting for you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
just your gently and touch upon the
skies
Adventures
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
believe me
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
brother
[Music]
[Applause]
good night
[Music]
waiting for the light
seems
[Music]
falling down
but not your own
a life that you never thought you'd know
[Music]
foreign
coming
[Music]
awaken for love
not your own a life that you'd never
thought you'd know
[Music]
foreign
desire
[Music]
d
back to my end
s
thank you
[Music]
remind me
[Applause]
[Music]
not the right one
foreign
[Music]
for you
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
the last time I saw
me
[Music]
yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
away
amazing
reasons
[Music]
you lost to me
surviving
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
time
far away
[Music]
all right
here
[Music]
far away
your answers
[Music]
I'm trying to
explain
[Music]
[Applause]
I can see your story
[Music]
victory
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
the last thing I do before
including
mine now from
[Music]
myself
[Applause]
[Music]
don't sign me to rest
okay
including where we both began
[Music]
[Applause]
I can see
my story
searching to find someone
to know me
I can see
[Music]
can't decide
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
too
until we can
you follow me
[Music]
foreign
together
[Music]
myself
foreign
[Music]
the Stars tonight What a Wonderful World
for
other life
waiting for you
in the Stars tonight
what a wonderful
for
[Music]
waiting for you
foreign
[Music]
you just you gently and touch upon the
sky
[Music]
surviving
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
waiting for the light
[Music]
but not your own
a life that you never thought you'd know
before
[Music]
when you are
in the time
awaken for love but not your own a life
that you never thought
[Music]
let this happen ing
thank you
to my end
a loving boyfriend
[Music]
in my
life
[Music]
foreign
everybody
[Music]
thank you
wait time
[Music]
yourself
foreign
[Music]
he's going down here
foreign
[Music]
hack this is the main stage make your
way over here we are going to start with
the Creator Gauntlet welcome to day one
dream hacks San Diego we have a lot of
fun stuff in store for you but today
it's it's going to be a fun one it's
going to be a fun one tell us about
what's going on well uh I'm very happy
to be here with the people so please
make some noise if you're excited for
the Creator gauntlet
thank you so much thank you so much I
want to know that people live and well
here you know but I'm gonna sit back and
relax here and I'm gonna let you know
exactly what are we doing here today
so what is the creator Gauntlet you
asked okay so the Creator Gauntlet is a
new initiative launched at dreamhack San
Diego for the first time which means
this is an exclusive you have many dream
hacks in the past but this will be the
first the very first time we do the
Creator Gauntlet so I'm pretty excited
for that
it's a battle where content creators
recruit their teams live here at
dreamhack San Diego and battle it out
against other creators and what's
beautiful about this it's all for
charity
yeah that's actually so officially so
every day same time we actually have
some stuff going on in the morning which
we'll tell you about in a second however
you're going to be here and we have our
team captains competing every single day
and Sunday we will Crown the winner of
the Creator Gauntlet and tell us a
little bit about the charity yeah yeah
so uh dream hack will be providing uh 25
000 prize pool that together with
donations throughout the event will be
donated to the Autism Society San Diego
so that's you you guys everyone that's
watching online donations will be going
to this wonderful local charity and it's
part of a bigger initiative that
dreamhack's doing so we're really happy
it's part of Autism Awareness Month
which is April that we're celebrating
here and really happy we can give
give back
that's crazy this is how you know I'm
live with all of this guys you know
we're just uh trying to get to know you
guys but these lights are killing me but
you know what that's just letting me
know that we're live in effect Live In
the Flesh so one more time Make some
noise for y'all man
for us and everybody
but yeah it's gonna be a pretty
exclusive weekend man we're gonna have
uh some fabulous content creators uh
battle it out throughout the weekend
which I'm very excited for for multiple
games I'm really excited about the
people we have coming I mean we have
some of your favorite content creators
here today we have uh some really
fantastic voice actors which is near and
dear to my heart that's going to be
really exciting too and they're all
going to be battling out in different
games can you tell us about the games I
got you so let's see just to give you a
little bit of the rule set of what's
going on here okay the team captains
will recruit their team members live
that means you guys but not today
because it's a special kind of event
where they invited their guest okay but
be on the lookout for that this whole
weekend you guys will be a part of the
show as well all right instead of just
being a viewer one one a few of you guys
are going to be lucky for that of course
uh teams will compete in various
challenges throughout the weekend such
as rock paper scissors
I'm excited for that I'm actually gonna
put some Bank on that on somebody
blindfolded fgc matches that's going to
be interesting that's the community that
I'm from so I'm actually looking forward
to that Mario Kart is the name of the
game today but there will be much more
throughout the weekend one of them is as
well is Resident Evil 4 so I'm excited
wait but also Mario today today is like
a themed Mario day so we're gonna have
Mario Kart then we're gonna have Mario
trivia
so we'll see you guys yeah
and then afterwards you'll be able to
watch the Mario movie which literally
came out this week on I think this stage
so if you guys want to watch a brand new
movie and not have to pay for it come
and hang out well I did not know that
uh pretty awesome to me that I can
actually watch this in person you know
so hopefully it is a great show
but yeah man uh so today is Mario Kart
just to give you a little bit of the
rules set here well one of the one of
the games is Mario Kart
the captains and their invited guests
will compete in a series of Mario kart
races to earn points for their team
so
we'll explain the points kind of as we
go
but at the end of the day Whoever has
the most points it'll accumulate over
the weekend and then we'll Crown Whoever
has the most points as the winner of the
Creator gauntlet
so
with further Ado let me introduce our
host I am your host Brittany Johnson uh
you might have recognized me from doing
voiceovers in different games hosting
but we have an amazing crew here yipes
you want to talk about yourself a little
bit well for those who may not know me
I'm known as IFC yipes and I represent
the Beloved fgc Community been in the
gaming field for about uh 20 plus years
when it comes to fighting games so if
you're familiar show me some love
I see y'all see y'all but for those that
are not there it is
also have a third host Super Special the
sweetest woman alive
yeah Make some noise
all right
hey guys so I am actually Alex B
um and I'll actually be at the Creator
Hub all weekend long we have some
awesome ones going on we have Pictionary
we have Rock Paper Scissors Shoot Battle
Royale with Team captains and audience
members and finally I should say last
but not least we have Matt versus all in
the ultimate game of chess this involves
exercise and chat so y'all better be
ready it will be amazing we will have a
blast and we will be at the Creator hub
so yeah Alex
uh now I'll say Let's uh get our team
captains out here right you ready for
that get ready for these introductions
y'all
yeah okay I'm just making sure y'all
with us to be honest all right okay so
let's start it off representing pasta
your bedtime I really gotta know the
Lord behind this because that's uh
pretty different Pastor your bedtime for
team blue give it up for nothing y'all
okay I'm putting a face to the Nay I see
you
okay okay
we're here come come over here
name yeah that is team blue that's my
favorite show the audience this cape the
captains get this beautiful cave to wear
we're all captains what's your team name
okay you get adorned
I hope it gives you some extra special
super power I feel faster already yeah
all right so you feel faster already
that's going to help you in Mario Kart
all right are you how are you feeling
about your competition yeah yeah I'm
feeling real confident right now first
person shooter background somehow is
going to help me out in Mario Kart and
uh I'm I'm good here the trivia the next
round I'm getting a little unsure about
but I think I'm gonna lean on my
teammate for that one I think there's a
way you know you're shooting the shells
okay no like what's your favorite item
to you is that your favorite item to use
in Mario Kart yeah something to do with
shooting something probably is my best
bet I expect the best accuracy possible
all right I have a quick a quick
question because I'm so curious like
this whole time I'm getting ready I'm
like yo what is Pastor your bedtime man
I can't lie I'm not really sure either I
think it's because I'm a father maybe
maybe I'm just like about to put my son
and all these competitors to bed oh my
God and he got bars poetic
she's well you know what I'm a fan works
for me brother all right just hang out
back here we're gonna get our next
Captain out here
okay so we have representing deep sea
divers
give it up for food sleep
I did say your name right right thank
you so much okay this is like a first
time thing for me come over here you
will be team red
that is so sick
you would think it's you would think
it's a cape or an apron because you
might cook tonight
I also love that you wore a mushroom
sweater because you came on brand today
it represents toad also what my cat's
name is mushroom I'm here representing
her and wow it's weird to hear my voice
hello okay sorry uh and I like mushrooms
and toads of mushrooms so is that who
you're gonna pick as your your champion
in Mario Kart today which Mario car are
we playing
good question good question
Mario
[__] Deluxe
the Baby Mario is in there
are you gonna switch sides from toad for
Baby Mario I play Baby Mario in Double
Dash so
I don't know I'll play toad toad yeah
toad team toad ladies and gentlemen
okay okay so that team red that is deep
sea divers
okay so representing Wildlife Alliance
please give it up for Ellen
oh my God I gotta step my game up in the
gym man Jesus Christ I see you're in
shape I know come right here Ellen I
feel like we should have given you blue
yeah
all right I like the money green
okay it's green like her eyes
yeah so Ellen are you just gonna destroy
your competition today yes
yes what'd you do to prepare
I I took a plane for 20 hours okay so
she's jet lagged a little bit Yeah like
it's a superpower okay it is a
superpower actually
well how do you feel about your
competition over here I'm really nervous
Maybe
and like other things not not this game
I hope I hope
well we've got a lot of stuff where you
compete in this weekend so we'll see how
you do in Mario Kart but you can always
come back
all right
okay okay that's what's up man damn they
are chirpy already I'm pretty excited
for this so it's gonna be good all right
but last but certainly not least and I'm
only saying this because I heard nothing
but great things about this guy okay so
representing team sea lions
Make some noise for John Sandman y'all
[Applause]
oh he's a people's champion is that guy
I gotta do my homework all you
are a light show too
I love the energy man seriously
seriously he's bringing me bringing me
alive
all right
all right I'm gonna get your cape gives
you a little extra super powers
tell me tell me how you're going to you
know go about this competition and win
today it's all a mind game so everything
I do is not going to be on the game it's
just gonna be me yelling at them and
trying to stop them from moving in the
game like a true gamer literally stop
them in their tracks maybe have them
like drive off the track a little bit
yeah I'm gonna get them to drive off the
track trust me I got my ways it's gonna
happen okay
okay all right he knows his way around
the car
all right so we've got their invited
guests you want to invite them all yeah
yeah so running with the homie nothing
for team Pastor your bedtime it's Luke
sankowski I hopefully I'm saying your
name right but please give it up for
Luke
[Music]
come over here and get laid
yeah that's bars I like that yeah wait
wait it's like he knew Luke Luke come
here come here
so have you played a lot of Mario Kart I
have played Mario Kart since the Super
Nintendo version so I'm you know I'm I'm
classically trained in the Mario Kart
Arts
and you have the blue hair the red the
team blue it looks like you got it all
yeah
represent and help a bunch of autistic
people like my best friend's daughter
Alex Ann she's awesome and and I'm
playing for her
that's amazing yeah go team blue
all right all right all right let's
listen along because I actually cannot
wait to see these folks burn rubble and
just uh Chuck shells right
uh but yeah for representing team deep
sea divers with fusley it's Lindsay
carroza
[Music]
that's right I did say your name right
right thank you so much Perfect come
right over here
okay I love this little pendant that you
have matches the team red Sheen like you
have got going on are you ready for
today I absolutely am
oh my gosh I'm so you get you're just
giving me good energy I feel like team
red has a really lucky player with them
we
eat the mushrooms and like didn't eat
five minutes five minutes ago
that do you guys
do you guys they're so in tune with each
other I feel like this is a dangerous
Duo this is a dangerous Duo all right
wow okay Kane prepared as usual well
here's Fire by the way all right so
representing with Ellen on Team Green
with Wildlife Alliance
give it up for John Allen
whoo
oh he's got the wave it's a nice way I
like that wrestling big wrestling fan
big wrestling fan oh yeah yeah yes yes
come over here let's get
wow so formal look at you guys are you
ready are you come back here
are you ready for some Mario Kart today
yes
okay go back
yo give it up for this man this man is
cultured for the wrestling game this man
just did the Triple H for people that
don't know that's the Hunter Hearst
Helmsley okay that's old school right
there but fine all right so of course
last but certainly not least who's
represented with my man John Sandman for
the sea lions give it up for Kyle carosa
[Applause]
[Music]
come right over here you're gonna get
get away all right team yellow look at
this colorful get up today everyone is
so on brand everyone just look at this
this is amazing are you ready for some
Mario Kart woohoo yeah
damn I really expect the entire time you
to be able to have those sounds going
absolutely all right perfect so I feel
like we should actually get this started
absolutely yeah are you guys ready
all right let's give it up for your
teams
so I think the captains go to the
couches I believe yeah and so we are
going to introduce our hosts Emma and
Bailey they're gonna come and join us
we're at game Squad giant bomb and
fandom they're the ones producing this
wonderful fun segment so enjoy
[Applause]
all right Racers if team captains could
please take a seat on the couches
and team captains sit on the couches and
invited guests why don't you stand
behind them for moral support
yes perfect they got capes yeah stand
behind your respective team captain
all right
here oh my God no what refresh rate is
this
I don't like this angle very much oh hey
you're all in position uh you'll find
that there are switch Pro controllers
that are on that uh little uh seat next
to you so everybody can grab a
controller go ahead and select your
Racers and please talk us through your
uh selection process I'm pink gold Peach
and uh oh who do you play that's really
hilarious to it I'll do daisy codette
[Music]
you know I'm a daisy Mane in Mario Kart
yeah yeah so are we I like that for you
yeah you're a daisy you're playing daisy
yeah that's a great choice one of my
great choice one of his favorite
characters
it works
all right so this is the way that this
is gonna work we are going to run a
series of races make sure that we turn
off computer players so it is only going
to be individuals playing no games I've
decided 150cc
that wasn't in the contract 150 cc I
thought it was 50 cc
150. whoever's player one I think has a
ticket this one yeah that one what does
it mean it just means it's harder yeah
you're gonna love it hey yeah you'll
love it somebody needs to hit it that's
that's
[Music]
all right excellent
loading oh
swag your cars
you are allowed to choose whatever
vehicle you like okay Emma gotta say if
there's one thing I love about my car in
real life and I did not build it myself
yeah I would build my car myself either
I'd be scared to drive before I built
myself no I see how my back runs I don't
want my car to do that
anything about the wheels do you like
you a wheel guy white tires glare
titanium is that a bike there's Claire I
can't play here
they're not unlocked how are we gonna
compete all right
yo those look fire is that cool all
right looks like we've got a what about
what about blimps
gorgeous cars I'm ready you tell me no
not the motorcycle
indecisive group I
think how you look in the game will
affect how you play I think so yeah it's
more about aesthetic what's the map all
right so uh we are ghosts too how do we
do go ahead and shoot I guess it wants
you to play a cup
okay
yeah we're doing a Grand Prix right they
want Rainbow Road I'm down first we
level one that ends with a rainbow
no I think am I deciding here are we
doing Rainbow Road yeah
do we have a preference does it matter
yeah I think you should pick that one I
like how the Star Cup is just half
airport start Grand Prix
stand up let's go in the zone here or
what how do you gas again
you're gonna lie to me are we gaming or
are we gaming we're gaming baby
[Music]
let's go
wait can we please go back upstairs
[Music]
that was so fun here let me set it up
good game everybody was that not one
thing that was perfect uh player one
yeah yeah who knows the warm-up yeah
four players it's a single uh oh is
someone not a part of that yeah
[Music]
there we go we got it perfect thank you
for your patience
I
was like we were in a versus race I
thought
the blood was pumping we were getting
ready
by the system before we are playing
I I think it's a possibility Madam and I
I hope that doesn't it isn't what
happens
shark in us I think she's a pro I don't
know any like um I gotta pick my back
skin she was like I don't play this
summer uh uh Microsoft that might be
here to sabotage the entire event yeah
I always think wait is it you picking
right now okay yeah
150 or 100. I like it oh so much better
okay great excellent bring it on 150 cc
here oh hang on let's go back uh top 50.
yep there we go okay 150. how do we say
anything
awesome all right all right
yeah
I didn't lie to you I'm talking to them
you're sabotaging I would never do that
we just met why would I that's why you
don't care
six point
oh
[Music]
what do you think our Racers chances are
today well one of them is gonna win
for sure I mean there is a winner in
there are no poker players
[Music]
they must have added that in the patch
can you window but you know the thing
that's great about being in last place
is that often entitles you to the best
items so true very possible to make a
big really nice back here as everyone
knows we're shooting green is that you
at the world
not that far ahead I just got hit by
another show oh
[Music]
oh I'm coming back baby
what is first place mean
each though
oh you can't drop bananas in the air
impressive performance
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go oh I got teamed up on
incredible stuff incredible stuff I'll
step it Up all right well I did I think
I was gonna be a second hell yeah what'd
you get you got second third I'm sitting
here second third fourth
[Music]
going for the next one
you're yeah you're playing the next one
yeah I see yeah if you didn't win you're
still in the race
so congrats to all the losers who simply
love to play Mario Kart I need to get
you on the mic
is there Electro bike the bike one is
that you pick Mario Kart hey pick it
wait wait actually I'm skip
oh that's scary excited you like knew
the name and stuff no I didn't Electro
bike this one's fun though I promise
if you don't win huh how you choose the
map yeah but it's fun Jordan like we'll
have a good time
what a choice
it's really it brings an air of
confidence
[Laughter]
it's kind of funny though did you ever
have those friends who like stood in
front of the screen and they're like
this one bling everyone
standing directly in front of the screen
do we want to touch the mud yeah stop
Little Peach might have just a really
good yeah maybe you're saying there's
not skill here but I think that was
skillfully built I think that it's a
it's a great build that she's not going
on
all right I think I had to switch my
bike
later
no no no
come on
there's a little snack while driving
like stopping at a fast food restaurant
Toadette bringing up the rear here but
looking so cute honestly that's the most
it's oil or mud
she was lying okay all right you got
called out we got a liar talk about a
Creator Clash look at them I've never
played before what did this do
I'm pretty much in first there we go
metal Peach too it's going around a lot
of mud puddles
still on life holding a strong lead here
really impressive stuff who's in first
metal you're dead
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
my God
[Applause]
what a win okay
Peach see it's rocket League
doesn't help now John my understanding
is that your invited guests here is
actually the one who got shows Daisy in
the first place he is the daisy Mane
well ladies and gentlemen may I
introduce the daisy Mane
[Applause]
he has blessed the controller we are
ready to race and we are ready to move
on to our next race
as our local Mario Kart ringer why don't
you choose our next stage oh you want to
choose
a fun and easy one not too many places
obviously I like it site bike now really
good find one that's just all mud
puddles yeah all mud puddles the more
mud puddles the better love a mud puddle
you know what I say can't have too many
mud puddles
good map
[Music]
oh it makes sense
all right what did we pick
oh
[Music]
because if you drive into a thing it's a
cow when you let's go baby
honestly don't encourage any kind of
animal guarantee
discourage it
they're not neutral on the on the
subject
oh I like this move
[Music]
wow grabbing an item what is it it's
here to play a tasty treat to eat
nice you are a mean player and I like it
skillfully avoiding that Hilltop God
like we could be nice IRL but in game no
yeah a person who's been in third place
fourth place this whole time finally
hitting their stride and taking the lead
and eating coin after coin let's go
one-two punch for Daisy knocking her
back into fourth place
what I want to know is what farmer is
taking care of these cows because they
are not doing them Farmer John
Farmer John get those cows back in their
house
you can catch up yeah you never do see
the proprietor
what they're going to give you the
bullet yeah
or those well if you find them I'd like
to have a word with him about his animal
handling skills come on Daisy
let's go oh it doesn't matter power
through it oh Yoshi expertly avoiding
the cows which is really the only thing
that matters you're fast you win if you
don't hit your back though she's doing
great you're stronger
you're better
[Music]
incredible work incredible time to swap
in your invited guests let's go the
mushroom fling is strong with this crew
we were talking backstage and she said
that she was pretty sure she was going
to be playing the whole time I'm glad to
see you've been all excuse me exactly so
as we move on to the last race of this
competition we have one win for
Sandman one win for fusely one win for
nothing
but you know what
and you Ellen you got this
you got this we believe in you so much
all right so for sure hey Emma do you
believe in her I believe in her okay
yeah yeah me too audience do you believe
in Ellen yeah let's go Ellen that's like
lukewarm let's try to
try it again
that's what I thought
good dodging Yoshi in seconds it's all
that Applause what is exact first place
for Yoshi but can Yoshi keep that lead
right in the mud puddles
yeah and I'm telling you yeah it's a lot
more than you think
what's wrong with it have fun the
infrastructure in Mario you don't
believe a lot to be desired
finish him yeah
yeah that's what I'm talking about
okay
[Music]
again
it might be
husband versus wife
the whole timer
in this relationship tonight
not like princess power or whatever
princess power
buying dinner tonight
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh she's got a piranha plan look at toad
that go that piranha plant is one of the
coolest items it is one of my favorite
items surely
let me believe that I too could be a
good Gardener and raise a plan
metal speech has gone free fully
underwater approach here oh did they
starve
yes
big points if you can pull this off oh
my gosh we've got Daisy we'd be leaving
lap three be known around these parts of
dreamhack oh man it's so close
[Music]
you don't need items
just a natural
human
with great strength oh my God
yes you jump over fire you are fired
careful Red's coming up you're right in
the butt that's not what you want a red
shelf I know you got it you got it
no Oh I thought that was the finish I
mean it was it wasn't it wasn't now is
it now they all look they look like that
I'm not crazy driving underwater that's
pretty bad for a metal complexion but
she seems to be muscling through
first place
[Music]
all right
no
actually uh what's supposed to happen
now and will happen now is uh
because you've won and you've already
won nothing uh You've Won nothing you're
well you've won nothing except the joy
of having played here on this stage
today uh what we need now nothing is for
you to choose somebody from the audience
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God
don't raise your hand
wait a sec
I need like I need some people
Undercover
Luke what do you think that's messed up
oh yeah I can't see anything
oh I think lady Waluigi you need it you
need it right here
oh my God
oh wow
Luigi Luigi here to save the day I'm
just saying hi
incredible I don't know
very difficult together
[Applause]
I see my buddy Adam out there I want to
say hi hi Adam all right
[Applause]
ooh with a sparkly
Luigi
all right lady Waluigi please take your
seat over here on the couch
I hope she knows how to not just play
the part yeah but also Mario Kart
[Laughter]
all right so let's go uh get out of the
screen here and go on we'll have to
probably start a new race but you know I
couldn't not spring the bringing
somebody from the audience up on stage
so I'm down with five courses let's do
it let's go oh let's go
let's settle this once and for all baby
Waluigi I'm rooting for you yeah
Ellen
hey they're they're scoring points
independently of how the game does it
we'll go over the sand example I'm just
gonna kind of walk around Luigi needs
her moment in the sun this is your time
to shine
please
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay
hey Yoshi
yeah
all right okay
all right
let's go rebuild these bikes slash cars
or do you know which one is the best no
stretching here
do you actually where are you making it
oh switching up their strats
Luke way to go
all right and this is going to be the
final race of the competition let's go
who will be the ultimate got his w got
it
honestly we couldn't have done it
without you
items I tried
I'm glad that Waluigi gets to play as
Waluigi it was it was really perfect
timing that we were starting a new
circuit
[Laughter]
all right Yoshi has built a pretty solid
are you guys looking at Stats yeah Ellen
is getting okay
lies in your resources of a stellar
place to end I would say yes Rainbow
Road a real classic I love it someone
won a rainbow road
it's for you oh no what does this mean
it's a little bit Halo
no this one you actually also have to
dodge the Covenant while you're driving
let's go they are gross
I'm personally ready for lady Waluigi to
be a ringer here I I just have a feeling
just absolutely dominant
it's the beginning of the game everyone
immediately slipping on every single
trap
Spirit of the game what does the money
do is there even any perks oh no
for anyone who can't hear what's going
on up here while Luigi's just going I
got
who's next
number one citizen Tacos on the second
floor invoice oh
some good Drifting by Waluigi here
Waluigi took the lead
with a swing and a miss on that on that
shell throat I know Red Shell now oh
you'll hold that banana back
you don't even have to release it
you're doing great
I'm gonna be honest with you
[Music]
all right I like that drop oh who's that
gonna get
what he's in first you're in first third
in a pretty tight battle with waluig I
don't want to make you feel comfortable
but like you're like the first class of
an airplane
you know
how do I perceive that
[Music]
nice
going for the Lower Road
all right look at them go they are coins
are great fast slow and steady wins the
race
okay you gotta skip yeah yes right yes
yeah right pick up a coin while you're
at it
Waluigi with a record
in range of somebody to unleash that
fury on a Target yes themed Yoshi right
in the bumper
that happened to me once all right okay
let's go
[Music]
yeah
yeah okay
it's our final it's happening Daisy is
in first Daisy are you afraid of us
nothing wrong lead no sheets let's look
at the aggregate
um
[Music]
that's it
thank you
sorry for Waluigi
but first in our hearts first in our
hearts Yoshi coming in third and
Toadette bringing up the room you're
still here
it's Helen layers
how's everybody feeling after that team
captain so good audience
all right excellent thank you for your
contribution we are going to yes how
about another uh
guys excellent
[Laughter]
you know
yeah we're going to take a second here
to tally up our standings do I need to
get another uh audience member
bye
amazing oh no all right great
all right Bailey what's the report wait
wait come back I didn't look at who it
was first and second is that what you
said
yeah
I don't know Luke do we need another
ringer
I don't know if we need another ring
we're getting the official report on
scores right now okay all right we have
two sets of ties
hard to believe I know but it was worth
it to bring lady Waluigi on stage so
why is this so funny
and nothing in the ceilings
sea lions and nothing are in first yeah
I'm so so sorry to our third place but
in order to determine the end of this
tournament and free everyone to go under
the floor some more except don't worry
don't do that continuing here actually
don't do that like immediately I forgot
what we were doing sorry
uh we will need to settle this old
school I need a representative the team
captain in fact from our first place
teams
come on over here
come join us on this side of the stage
I don't see any competition oh
literally for the first time in my life
I will say this I'm literally taller
than you you are
it's rare not if I stand on my victory
here I did wear high shoes yeah this is
some solid trash talk but trash talk
doesn't win rock paper scissors oh
really oh yeah oh we're doing a one two
three shoot yeah
no one shoot are you sure you're ready
for this yeah are you ready wait you're
getting in my head right now stop are we
doing it just right now just naturally
Paper Scissors Shoot Rock Paper Scissors
Shoot Rock Paper Scissors Shoot okay let
me think this before I played this
before hold on hold on
that's my teammate he knows yeah all
right don't you dare ask your teammate
all right all right here we go rock
paper scissors get in the zone are you
two ready always okay let's settle this
all right one two three Rock Paper
Scissors Shoot oh my God
that's him wasn't me it wasn't me
strategy from the teammate
congratulations Sandman that makes you
the overall winner of the Mario Kart
segment of the Creator Gauntlet
here
San Diego love to see it and look at
that sportsmanship impressive we're
actually fighting after sportsmanship
um let's go drink now we're gonna have a
a quick little change over the Mario
Madness the scissors statues right here
on this stage because coming up in just
a moment it's going to be time to test
the Mario knowledge of all of our team
captains and their invited guests in our
Mario trivia competition so don't go
anywhere
and please
welcome to back to the stage
our hosts
[Applause]
appreciate it
scissors are you kidding me all right
who is surprised that Sandman won
not us sorry are you surprised like you
thought he was whack and then he showed
improved or like what
I like this guy Sam hey
you're my guy just remember the strategy
that he came with
actually like was proven so way to go
all right but we need nothing Ellen we
got you guys gotta make up now in Mario
trivia right yeah
all right so I know everything about it
tell everyone about Mario trivia well
guys of course no secret next is Mario
trivia I said Mario Mario trivia there
you go got it this is a Who Wants To Be
A Millionaire style trivia presented by
FanDuel with Nintendo and Mario themed
questions this is going to be
interesting I actually want to know
how's this going to go okay captains
will each compete to see how far they
can get and make smart use of their
lifelines to survive lifelines they got
life okay
[Music]
makes sense all right okay I will say we
are going to switch out the guests so
the captains will stay but oh wait wait
I need your lace
no wait we're gonna have other bags
[Music]
I need you we'll remember
all the times we've had together oh my
God
[Music]
oh you did amazing
amazing
Elementary School graduation I remember
it well that's my eighth grade
you're showing my ears
that's my Elementary School five seven
five eight like okay all right we got
this going all right so this next little
bit is actually a bit unfair because we
got Warp Zone here today and their
knowledge in gaming in general is just
absurd and they're just so much fun to
watch so although we are splitting them
up against each other so this will be a
really fun like little competition to
watch so let's get our new teammates out
here we're gonna start off with
who do I want to start off with all
right we're going to start off with Team
pasta your own bedtime
yeah what am I doing
Michael Schroeder ER Michael Michael
I need you here Michael you're a mic
is is this my guy this is your guy
wearing a Mario shirt he had a Mario
shirt on yeah that's how I'm gonna win
wait what Hey listen man I'm just
shaking hands your name is Michael
that's it
I'm Gonna Leave actually Michael Jordan
should we all hang out all right sorry
all right so you guys made a video where
you said you were getting ready for for
Mario today we're ready I'm super ready
I've studied so hard and entire minutes
of study you have the shirt and
a shirt so I got this unlock got it
unlocked all right well take a a receipt
or whatever uh yeah yeah next uh you're
taller than me so behind me
thanks John I'm really insecure Michael
Davis
please
okay okay my partner great we only
wanted Michaels for this next one
yes oh yeah
[Music]
over here
so practice minutes
just watch the 90s Mario movie so I'm
gonna win this whole thing what just on
that yeah okay
have you
listening he's a voice of Mario you
ready the voice of Mario Bob Hoskins
maybe that might be a question
said this might be okay go sit down next
are you wafting right here behind me
you're on my team
all right
let's see if John Sandman can keep the
winning streak going because he has no
that's good that's Odem on his team come
on Autumn yeah my team yes yes your guy
hey let's go baby let's go
could you also watch the 90s video movie
absolutely not I did I watched their uh
I watched our own video on the 90s movie
that's why you have to stop breaking it
down
guys
[Laughter]
push it with your man let's go
[Applause]
we got it I got this and last but not
least with Ellen we have Brian Fisher
yeah
boo
[Music]
um what we're supposed to talk about
what do you do to prepare so I thought
we were going to be on the same team and
that Schroeder was gonna have all the
knowledge and I feel pretty screwed
right now
I'm sorry Ellen
who has me do
you do that
who shall I marry they have the leash
backstage they'll have to grab that okay
great
like give me the mic back give me that
give me this Warp Zone together is like
a force to be reckoned with but you
separate them and everything starts
falling apart
all right so let's get come on guys this
is giga mom out here we got curve and
Giant Bomb Giant Bomb I I know that was
a joke earlier that I was gonna call him
gigabomb and then I subconsciously did
it it was beautiful I would have it no
other way soft launch new company uh
we're gonna be hosting this thing I'm
growing from giant bond this is Dan um
so much guys 25 over here and more I
don't know
plus two times two all right so I got
the game right here we're gonna get it
set up but it is Who Wants To Be A Mario
Nair like that it's Who Wants To Be A
Millionaire rule is everyone's familiar
uh with that like set up it's gonna be
exceedingly difficult questions yeah the
early questions are very simple uh keep
that in mind that's important don't say
that multiple choice yeah just hey hey I
want you to guess C every time all right
are we going one at a time or do we like
yell so I don't even know we're gonna
have a kind of a soft timer don't don't
take an exceedingly long amount of time
I will rush you if I feel I need to but
otherwise don't feel pressure about that
cool should feel pressure about is your
three lifelines your first Lifeline is
a Mario World Record holder he has a
Guinness World Record for playing a 50
hours of Mario 50 hours straight Mario
it's Mario Scotland it's still holding
this is your one of your experts each
one of you could call on him once what's
his name his name is Dan Dan I'm Dan
I play too much Mario so be careful calm
down your other one is a 50 50. you
whenever you want it's gonna help
everybody though keep that in mind true
at any time you could call this say 50
50. I'm gonna take away two of the wrong
answers so there'll be one right one one
wrong one and and then uh the other one
is what's the other Lifeline hang on let
me see here uh we were gonna do crowd uh
we were going to do um audience let's
see here oh the point double that's
right Point doubler so this is why it's
important to know the questions get
harder as we go along because yeah you
could use it earlier but they're worth
less money you're more likely to get
away but it's worth less money wait to
the end it's gonna be harder but you
might get more money so it's risk reward
all right it's everyone Gotta Have a
good idea yeah
let's get into it yeah
so we're supposed to write downstairs
yeah I hope wait for all the questions
we get to collaborate like you guys like
you and yourself you guys know you guys
should be able to see the feed of the
questions on this confidence monitor
once it comes up
but we're getting that worked out right
now so like again though like say if we
know the answer and multiple know the
answer do we
is it in turns or no so you guys have
your white boards right here yeah yeah
your teammates behind you have white
boards oh everyone answers at the same
time okay okay and then okay so if they
give it something first it doesn't
matter as long as we all get we're all
gonna be holding up at the same time
we're gonna say okay here's the right
answer and then we'll see who gets the
right answer okay got our buddy Dave out
here keeping track of points don't worry
about it all right all right all right
b c d a b c or D you're gonna get the
hang of it real fast
and it's also you don't lose it and you
could agree or disagree we could talk
about it
are we gonna be able to bring up the uh
the game for everybody
[Music]
because they can hear us talking you got
to do it you guys hear me yeah yeah you
guys should get better from over here I
don't trust them so when we're talking
to them and giving them yeah you guys
are on teams you're allowed to talk to
each other but like I'll hear them is it
okay that everyone hears it should we do
code words the they'll do their best to
uh to try to turn off during the perfect
quietly I don't think let's mute these
guys when we're actually getting the
answers everybody
[Music]
all right uh
all right I'm gonna do one last check
okay
all right they're gonna figure it out
right now guys
all right so again when we're actually
doing the answering if you guys want to
have a little conclave we'll try to make
sure the bikes are turned off if not
hold them away
hold them away do your best
foreign
they're trying to get it up on the board
right now we're almost there we're
almost there
there we go right there we go okay
everyone go ahead and take a peek at
this confidence monitor over there
you're probably gonna have a hard time
reading the words but I will read them
out to you right now let's get started
are you guys ready to go
I'm gonna take that as a yes
all right your first question
what is the name of the main antagonist
in the Mario series is it a Wario B
Bowser C Donkey Kong or D Waluigi
go ahead and write your answer as A B C
or D on the board
and when everyone's ready
like I said starting off easy yeah
is everyone ready we're ready we are all
right we're here yeah
the correct answer is
B what's going to see everybody Yeah
final answers all right easy
so everybody got B right all right
smallest B Refrigeration all right so
everybody we're going to take a time
after each question make sure we gotta
make sure we get it yeah we got this all
right good job let's move on
thank you
who is the voice actor for Mario Luigi
Wario and more is it a Al Gore for sure
Al Gore I trust you George Washington
why is this a question see George
Clinton or D Charles Martin a happy
does everyone feel good about this yeah
you guys ready everyone's wait wait wait
wait we're not ready
you think it's that come on
just look behind you
oh there's another egg Al Gore B George
Washington C George Clinton or D Charles
Martin a
h no what you guys right
no I'm just not one of your lifelines
do you think it's that I don't know I
think it's no no no no do that but yeah
I'll take that I'll take that all right
show your boards let's see what everyone
had to say yes
oh sorry the correct answer is it's
gonna be so embarrassed if we got that
wrong I hope we didn't know that
everybody got it right we're just
getting the crowd hyped all right let's
move on to the next one
it's gonna be a long night you guys are
doing great so far remember you have all
your lifelines you can use them whenever
you like oh my God what in 2013 which
sibling did Nintendo celebrate for an
entire year a Luigi B Daisy how do you
know this C Waluigi
I think Boshi is a ball
wait oh she's a character yes not a ball
a bushy ball
I like the confidence I'm seeing over
here is everyone ready uh are you ready
you know
write your write your favorite letter
okay let's see the boards
yeah no it says a the correct answer is
hey let's go
that was the Year of Luigi as I'm sure
we all remember many babies born that
year
oh no good job
Dan how you feeling about their
performance so far hey 100 success rate
you know no complaints here they know
they're Mario let's get to the next
question
what was the name of the first game to
feature Luigi was it a Donkey Kong B
Mario Brothers C Super Mario World or D
Game and Watch oh this is right
this is still a 100 point question but
they are beginning to get a little bit
trickier
hey Dad uh yeah are you officially
calling me is this your lifeline you be
careful that you don't want to use that
now that's how dangerous all right we're
feeling good
thanks for checking on my boy no
Lifeline yet pretty sure how you guys
doing live we're great you guys have
your lifelines
wait if we get out are we out out no
there is no out you're just gonna you're
just gonna fall behind we're gonna start
anything right so far
I feel like it's too obvious but maybe
that's the answer
yeah oh we bought that too
did you yeah all right answer keep it
you guys we need an answer
there we go and of course all right
let's show our boards let's see everyone
goes oh we got B we got one oh all right
the correct answer is that was Mario
Brothers
[Music]
I wanted them actually
one life
and on my back
yeah
did you guys know that answer I didn't
all right let's do one more
all right next question
100 bucks what is the name of the
turtle-like enemies that Mario
Encounters in his games a Goombas
accordingly bloopers
C cheap Jeeps Koopa troopas
the 90s movie was great it was a great
movie no the turtle-like enemies that
Mario Encounters in his game that actor
you know yeah
of course we know this
if you don't know this you're crazy
everyone feeling good everyone ready
yeah let's show the board oh wait we
still need a minute
let's see the boards everybody the
correct answer of course is D Koopa
Troopers
it's right for everybody
you knew that too
all right
in which game did Yoshi make his first
appearance is it a Super Mario Brothers
B Super Mario World C Mario Kart or D
Mario Tennis that's not Boshi that's
Yoshi yes yeah do it what you feel
anyone know where boshi's from uh I
would have guessed
Super Mario RPG that's right yeah well
done
directions
okay we could be wrong but honestly
we're probably not they're looking all
right
we would never everyone ready they're
calling it they're saying we're cheating
we don't appreciate that all right
that's uh listen that this is some hot
stuff over here yeah we're gonna call
Dan over you guys don't want me to call
Dan over let's see everybody's boards
yeah everybody's boards everyone got B
yeah yes that's good because that's
correct well let's go
[Laughter]
all right we are moving into the 200
Point questions
let's do it in Super Mario Sunshine one
of Dan's favorite games what is the name
of the device that Mario uses to clean
up the graffiti in Isle Delfino is it a
flood
B hoes
C mop or D broom Mario Sunshine hey grub
yeah would you call this game a
masterpiece dad I would not either I
would I know you would yes he was
wearing a Super Mario Sunshine shirt
we found a fan so you know what it's a
masterpiece you're right beautiful you
know
you guys are so impressive as a team
well I said are we still working it out
across this question really always don't
have some people writing down the
answers
what is this guy doing
that's right
all right are we ready yeah yeah we're
ready we're running out of time is
everyone got something written down yeah
yeah all right let's show the boards
oh
oh my God okay we got some C's we got
some bees got some A's shameful
shameful what's the correct answer you
really did this on note cards
blood everyone's praying no all right
don't erase yours let's see so you guys
said c yeah you guys said B so team
yellow Team Green all right we're on it
pasta your bed is fine
all right well done so far things are
gonna start getting harder it is
probably time since we're like missing
some questions think about your life
flying lifelines think about your point
doublers that last question take a look
500 points but do you really want to
risk it at that point
that's what it is all right let's get to
the next question if you're really
confident huh
yes
no it's way yeah
in Super Mario Bros 3 what is the name
of the power up that turns Mario into a
statue
is it a frog suit B Tanooki Suit C
Hammer suit D bear suit that one right
or is that wrong
you thought it was something else
we have the teams working together
go with your gut some fellas looking
lost I mean that sounds the most like it
Mighty dinner after let's get some tacos
and they're working it out we still okay
but why
wait a minute
how are we doing wait wait wait no no
still got one more writing does that
sound more like it
I believe in you go with your gut
you think but you think all right okay
everybody let's see those boards
oh oh oh b b c b damn it you're all
wrong
those are your final answers the correct
answer is am I proud of you what B yeah
okay good I got in my head nice I got in
my head you're right you're right
thanks man I was pretty sure all right
yeah
how's everybody feeling really good you
guys a lot of you are on a roll camera
it's gotten most of them yeah
listen anything can happen you all still
have all your life so if we want to do
double points we can do that separately
or we do it as it only applies to you oh
so you should use it a couple points
to your team if we get it wrong you do
not lose anything extra but you would
not have a chance to do double later on
gotcha although right now we're the 200
Point questions we're going to be 400
soon can you stack your double and your
Lifeline yeah you can use all your life
oh
throwing out whoa
all right here's our next question uh-oh
what is the name of the last level in
Super Mario Brothers
a rainbow road
B Star Road I don't think I ever see my
life one here Bowser's Castle
D eight four go with it
oh I should clean that up
it feels like a trip the last level in
Super Mario Brothers easy locked in
sign it
[Laughter]
give me the silver
we got everyone writing everyone's
writing down yeah
I'm confident if you guys all want to
use your lifelines
do you use lifelines right now
I think does everyone have something or
are we still going to use our lifelines
I like it we're not you see the board
flip them around
yo yeah everyone says d
let's take a look what a great drawing
on top and the answer is yeah
let's go where we're going everybody
[Laughter]
if you rub the Sharpie out it kills
antagonist in Super Mario Bros all right
this is your last 200 question uh-oh you
guys have been doing very well
I think I have a fake that you guys are
going to be able to do really well in
the 400 questions but now is your last
chance to use it on what is somewhat an
easier question yeah for sure for 200
what is the name of the main antagonist
in Super Mario Brothers 2 a Mauser B
Pokey
the main antagonist from Super Mario
Brothers 2.
what you vibing with
it
[Laughter]
steam talking about Darth Vader okay
um
everyone's still thinking
we're good
yes let me see the guess
I think it's a really cute name though
I like it yeah
I love both characters we haven't seen
these names Mario games if you don't go
way back to the NES
what would you name it
we're ready right is everybody ready
yeah yeah
all right let's see those boards
oh no
[Music]
nuts uh let's get to it did we lose this
one
the correct answer is is it D please be
B
itch it's
oh my God correct answer the correct
answer was D
yellow and green missed outwards I said
Pokey right yeah we did yep all right
yep warts uh the big frog he hates
vegetables yes he really hates him have
you played all the games all right now
named the wrong name
it's Super Mario Brothers 2 which
character can pull vegetables out of the
ground the fastest
hey Mario he didn't even know he's Luigi
C peach or D toad yo I know this one
even I know this you guys should have
used your 50 50 here no no I know this
one 100 you know you guys actually
should use your 50 50.
I think I think lifelines I think
that you do not get extra points it's my
favorite character
50 50 but I don't know it at all right
I really respect that yeah but you
should use it we'll use it later okay
yeah
okay um
let's take a look here
they can't I said before that they could
use other people someone else does a 50
50 they can do it oh wait we can't you
want to make us ride it first before I
was thinking about it that's kind of
cool let's do it okay unless you guys
also want to use your 50 50. so you have
to write your answer now before I do the
50 50. this is my favorite character
only it will only be for you it's so
biased
good call
let's do it right I feel like there's
nothing about it right now
the drama's building tension all that
are you gonna use the lifeline I think
you guys are going to use a 50 50 as
well
what would you mind
you're gonna ask him all right so all
right we have ours written well in that
case all right uh we're gonna do the 50
50 first and then you guys
the lock in the 50 50 and then I'll help
them yeah exactly so all right
all right I'm gonna hit the 50 50. no we
did not
yeah please oh shoot oh yeah okay oh no
no no no no no no changing no change
he's rounding the numbers in the
audience he's just rounding it up he's
just rounding it up
all right take that marker away
okay thank his marker
seriously did you win
all right my bad okay
so yes now you get to ask the expert dad
any question is in Super Mario Brothers
2 character could pull vegetables out of
the ground the fastest Luigi b or toad D
my answer with 100 confidence is Toad
yeah
wow 100 confidence
[Laughter]
all right we are all locked in let's
show our answers to the audience
yellow is wrong they got they got it a c
we messed up everyone else got it all
right well done everybody good job
[Laughter]
oh man we have lifelines and we're
almost at the end
did anyone from the audience know that
one the composer of the music yeah
really Mario they've known everything
all right next question are you ready
yes we are ready who is the composer of
the music and audio for Super Mario
Brothers
Miyamoto what are the three lifelines
again 50 50. we can ask Dan and uh you
could do the point doubler oh
we could stack him too you have a point
doubler and uh you guys used to ask ask
him so you have a 50 50 left okay that's
all yep
you know what go with it
I'm sorry for my pronunciation it's not
very good we'll try to try to save it
yeah
do you have any idea
all right how's everybody feeling uh
we're good
are we all locked in do we want a 50 50
this one or you think you know
do you want it okay I think are you guys
yeah wait should we also Point double
and point double I mean that's fine so
we can get that 100 points what do you
think
all right
okay they're gonna lock in their 50 50.
that means unless and we're gonna Point
double yes I got you don't thank you all
right have everyone else lock in their
answers go ahead and show me
show me
show me real quick we're locked in the
show he's locked in okay all right we're
locked in okay so let's do the 50 50. oh
gosh
are you happy with your locked in
answers
okay I forgot the game so we're gonna
let me do it once so I'll we'll fake it
for you okay cool all right so take away
a and take away B okay I think so
they're 50 50. between C Koji condo and
D Shigeru Miyamoto I'm confident in that
too the other name does not sound
familiar at all yeah
[Laughter]
let's show those boards
please
what the oh all right before
the correct answer is if it's D I'm
gonna cry
and I see
please we see
coach
that's good that's big that's big that's
huge
all right you guys got that naturally
you got that pre 50 50. you got that
naturally yeah we are down to the final
three questions it is not going to get
easier but we're kind of those lifelines
now is the time to use them yeah all
right let's do it
what do we have left Lifeline Liz
yeah what do we have
oh it's ask what was the name
pan
think about this question
what was the name of the American Super
Mario Brothers 2 in Japan a Super Mario
Brothers the lost levels B Super Mario
Brothers 2 special Edition
see Super Mario Brothers USA or D Doki
Doki Panic I like the last one it sounds
that is that I feel like this one's a
joke that one's like it's not a joke but
like they're trying to with the question
I could be wrong
okay
think
it just Auto wrote for you on your board
thank you
you're talking about my door think about
the questions the American Lifeline
Super Mario Brothers too okay
um
let's go I feel happy because you failed
once
kind of like this I kind of like this
one
you know this one does it sound how's
everybody doing exciting
do we want to use any lifelines okay
what did you end up doing yeah I I think
I I think I know it is all right I'm
gonna need people to start locking in
those answers I know I'm trying to Let's
you filming this one more all right are
we ready let's do it let's do it let's
go with our original vibe
did you get their point double for the
last time oh man
okay so everybody ready yep all right
let's see those boards
oh my goodness oh
three of us all right it's between Super
Mario Brothers and lost levels are you
proud of Mario Brothers USA
we said it are those even the correct
answers
the correct answer is
in America what
C Super Mario Brothers USA wow well done
everybody wow oh we still got lifelines
all of them you can use all of them in a
while
double points on 500.
genius that's crazy all right here's my
personal favorite question for the
children for the children yeah let's get
sexy I was almost done in which game can
you make Bowser kiss Mario
is it a Super Mario
Odyssey
yeah it was literally Mario RPG
story or D Hotel Mario is Hotel Mario a
real game I don't know this
[Music]
but is he a big kissing fan
keep in mind he does not know everything
Dan the question is in which Mario game
can Bowser which game can Bowser kiss
Mario I'm gonna have him answer one
second
does anyone else that's good expert
because otherwise you have to lock it in
I don't question you
oh
yeah if we double now I can and then
they double next Point what's the point
total that's a good question we could uh
check in
I think it should be
all right here we go
so which uh okay so team red my people
team red has two thousand seven hundred
dollars I don't know Team Green has one
thousand two hundred but now you're
probably right team blue has 2 300. Team
yellow also has two thousand three
hundred what are we are you guys good
you could like stand close to him or
something red 2007.
and if we get any other uh Revelations
we can change it okay we're locking in
all right you guys are locked in
are you guys locked in okay we're gonna
here let me let me guys just take a peek
on here
uh we did B
fair enough all right uh you want a
chance to ask an expert all right Dan
um can you make Bowser kiss Mario a
Super Mario Odyssey B Super Mario RPG
see Mario and Luigi Bowser's Inside
Story or D Hotel Mario now I'd say my
specialty is mostly in the platformer so
I can say it's definitely not a
now B and C are RPGs I've played them
I'm not as much of an expert so I'll
give you like a 60 confidence level
I'm gonna say
it's B
please
as well they're double in it okay
all right a lot of money on the line now
I want to get it let's go ahead and see
those boards
come on baby
everyone going everyone
it is it's gonna be me the correct
answer is
foreign
[Music]
s left we're gonna we're gonna use it
we're gonna double up and ask a guy we
have an ask
okay
here's your question okay for sure not
yeah let's read the question then we'll
figure all that out cool according to a
Nintendo brand Bible what is Yoshi's
species name
a t yoshisor munchakoopus
Turtle dragon
C Saddleback Soros D crocodilian who we
are and keep in mind that C's over here
and T's over there it's all messed up
because it's a cheap website for
teachers
so I believe
so what we'll need to do is um look at
the letters yeah
okay let's figure this out I think what
we'll do is you guys need to lock in
bless you okay so they're locking in uh
you guys are going to use yeah yeah Dan
all right what we're going to do is
I'm gonna do I'm gonna 50 50 you guys
off to the side real quick
okay all right okay wow all three you
did save them you said you're gonna do
that I didn't believe you
as well right
okay all right all right is that right
all right now here is your chance to ask
a Dan Dan according to a Nintendo brand
Bible what is Yoshi's species name a t
Yoshi store muchakupas B Turtle Dragon C
Saddleback Soros or D crocodilian it's
gonna be the most fun one to say t
yoshisor muchakupas yeah
so that's
he said t Yoshi says a stretching
oh my God
[Laughter]
Jersey
what's going on there's no is everybody
ready I don't know it could be
all right
let's go ahead and show those boards
come on come on we all got it hey oh
family Affairs
okay all right it is I was
the correct answer is but no no hey
let's go
oh he's got the points
he does this is our guy
we're gonna check this out one second
how did everybody feel about it
yeah you're very knowledge man behind me
I didn't think we're gonna bring in the
ringers
that's cheating did you get our thousand
in there
don't you check it
if it matters
he's like slipping him a 20 bill I got
you man all right we have the results
all right what teamwork color are we
again
pasta your bedtime your team blue I'm
team blue wait all right I'm colorful
there's no way
fourth place with 2600 points
Team Green Wildlife Alliance
congratulations yeah
yeah team yellow hey
Lions well done we did great we did
great we did great
that takes us to our winner
as well as the runner-up tied uh-huh
okay we have a runner-up we have a clear
one
with a 300 Point difference
[Music]
wow winners are
the red team
for 3 700 points well done everybody
yeah
good job everyone say thank you
everybody that was a lot of fun that was
nice very fun thank you thank God
every single one right yeah
thank you
hey let's see let's hear from our
contestants you didn't get one wrong
especially the red team well done you
got them all let's hear it for our Mario
World Record holder again yeah
[Applause]
and I'm Jeff thank you so much guys that
was great we're gonna we're gonna wrap
this up right now I think that does it
for us today you guys are going to be
back later this weekend right you guys
are still all weekend yeah all right I'm
looking forward to that thank you
everybody for watching until next time
take care of yourself goodbye
people
[Music]
I can see
together with donations to the event
will be donated to the Autism Society
San Diego so thank you guys for that
okay you guys can donate everything at
the end whoever wins it will be going
towards uh the Autism Society San Diego
I believe yeah and so and that is we're
here to celebrate and and give back to
the community it's also Autism Awareness
Month for April so look at dreamhack
yeah yeah but uh look at us you guys
want to know what's going on tomorrow
before we sign off
all right so I know there's a lot of uh
fgc fans in here so say James will it
kill will be on this stage tomorrow at 4
P.M who's excited for that
I was wrong when you you're gonna play
that game with me tomorrow I got bodied
I got smoke so it is what it is then we
got blindfolded fighting game matches at
5 p.m interesting I hope so it's all
sound cues I'm pretty sure rock paper
scissors Battle Royale and that will
start at 6 p.m that's the one I'm
looking forward to the most
and uh yeah that's for Saturday so guys
uh just catch-ups tomorrow at 4 P.M
start time
yeah well also have some stuff also
happening at the Creator Hub with your
host Alex that's during the day those
points count as well I think they should
so everything will all accumulate
we're gonna give away the prize Sunday
make sure you come back here we're gonna
have all new invited guests your
favorite creators as the team captains
coming back and it'll be a fun time
well that's it well guys see you
tomorrow good night
foreign
[Music]